Die Web ist nur weniger als 5000 Tage alt. Es ist wirklich unglaublich, dass all diese Sachen hier sind. Und also eine der Dinge, die ich denke, wir lernen, wenn man über Wikipedia denkt, ist es etwas, das einfach unmöglich ist. Es ist unmöglich in Theorie, aber unmöglich in der Praxis. Und wenn du all diese Dinge nimmst, die unmöglich sind, denke ich, dass eines der Dinge, die wir in der letzten Dezember lernen, ist, dass wir gut an das Unmöglich glauben müssen, weil wir unbereit für es sind. Also, ich habe eine einfache Geschichte, und es zeigt, dass das, was wir denken wollen, ist das Ding, das wir machen, das Ding, das in 5.000 Tagen passiert ist, dass wir aus all diesen Verbindungen eine Maschine bekommen.
Hier hört CRE Technik, Kultur, Gesellschaft. Mein Name ist Tim Pritlove und das hier ist die 205. Ausgabe von CRE. Und ja, alle schreien ja immer hier, mach doch mal wieder was über Technik und so, immer die ganze Kultur und die Gesellschaft. So soll es sein. Aber trotzdem habe ich mir ein Thema ausgesucht, wo auch die Gesellschaft und die Kultur durchaus mit drin hängt, aber auch die Technik ist hier sehr interessant. Kurz gesagt, es geht um Wikidata, ein Projekt aus der Wikipedialandschaft, noch relativ neu und irgendwie weiß keiner so richtig was darüber. Und da wollen wir jetzt mal was gegen unternehmen. Und dafür habe ich mir Jens eingeladen, Jens Ohlig. Ja, Jens, du bist ja hier auch schon so ein bisschen Dauergast, ne?
Dauergast kann man nicht sagen. Also ich glaube, ich bin jetzt das erste Mal mit dem neuen Vorspann-Gast.
Ach so, ja gut, aber trotzdem.
Obwohl, ich weiß es nicht, es gab schon mal Sendungen, ja.
Genau, wir haben schon mal ein paar Sendungen gemacht und auch zu sehr unterschiedlichen Themen, so ein bisschen der Zukunft und Hackerbrause war hier auch ein Thema. Du bist ja sehr umtriebig in dem gesamten Technik-Kulturellen-Umfeld. Und so gefühlt hast du auch schon so an 1000 Projekten teilgenommen, ne?
Kann man so sagen, also mir ist heute Morgen noch mal mit Strecken aufgefallen, dass das jetzt, also mein 20-jähriges CCC-Kongress-Jubiläum habe ich einfach verschlafen. Das ist jetzt irgendwie 22. oder 23. Kongress für mich und so, ja.
Da fühlt man sich schon ein bisschen alt. Genau, also bist ja auch im Clubumfeld schon lange unterwegs und da mit diesen ganzen Entwicklungen der letzten Jahrzehnte ganz gut vertraut. So, und jüngst, muss man dann schon fast sagen, in Relation dazu, hat es dich zu dem Wikimedia-Projekt verschlagen.
Genau, also ich bin seit, also im April werde ich dann ja zwei Jahre Mitarbeiter von Wikimedia Deutschland sein und bin ursprünglich eingestellt worden für ein Projekt, über das wir heute reden, Wikidata, was aber für ein Jahr befristet ist und war und natürlich läuft da immer noch ganz viel Entwicklungsarbeit auf Hochtouren, aber ja, mein Titel jetzt ist einfach, dass ich Mitarbeiter bei Wikimedia Deutschland bin und in der Software-Entwicklungsabteilung dort.
Genau, aber nichtsdestotrotz hast du mit Wikidata nach wie vor sehr viel Tuchfühlung, aber du gehörtest auch zu dem Team, was dieses Projekt dann überhaupt erst mal losgetreten hat.
Richtig, also es ist eine relativ spannende Geschichte, wie das überhaupt geklappt hat. Also Wikimedia Deutschland hat mal angefangen als ein ganz kleiner Verein von Leuten, die als Autoren in der deutschen Wikipedia unterwegs waren und dann wuchs es und wuchs es und hat den Fokus auch immer weiter verändert. Und mittlerweile sind wir über 50 fest angestellte Mitarbeiter dort, was schon für eine NGO, die digital aktiv ist, relativ bemerkenswert ist. Also es gibt auch, glaube ich, in Berlin zumindest nichts Vergleichbares in der Größe. Und es geht auch weit darüber hinaus, nur ein Online-Lexikon zu befüllen. Und da ist dann auch ziemlich heftig und ziemlich plötzlich dieser Bereich Softwareentwicklung dazugekommen bzw. dieses Wikidata-Projekt. Ursprünglich war das halt so, dass ja MediaWiki, die Software, die darunter liegt, halt von Freiwilligen im Internet entwickelt wird. Dann, als sich das ein bisschen professionalisiert hat und die ersten Leute fest angestellt wurden, hat sich das dann alles in San Francisco im Sitz der Wikimedia Foundation abgespielt. Und Leute haben entweder Telecommuting gemacht, also irgendwie in Amsterdam gesessen und per IRC ihre Arbeitsaufträge aus San Francisco abgeholt oder sind halt irgendwie gleich dahin gezogen. Und das dann auf einmal eine Softwareentwicklungsabteilung aus dem Boden gestampft worden ist, um ein Softwareprojekt durchzuziehen. Das war, glaube ich, ein großes Experiment für diesen kleinen Enzyklopädie-Verein in Berlin, wo dann halt auch auf den Schlag ein Dutzend Leute eingestellt wurden. Ein Team aus allen möglichen Ländern, also Kollegen aus den USA, aus Belgien, wir hatten Kollegen aus Norwegen am Anfang dabei. Das wurde dann halt so richtig gecastet und das war ja in mehrlei Hinsichten ein Experiment, weil Wikimedia Deutschland nicht wirklich Erfahrung damit hatte, was das heißt, ein großes Software-Projekt aufzuziehen. Das Projekt ist halt auch eigentlich ziemlich groß und es wurde halt von dritten Mitteln dann auch bezahlt, also es ging halt nicht um diese Spenden, die man dann zur Weihnachtszeit absetzt, wenn man auf der Wikipedia rumsurft und dann plötzlich oben dieses gelbe Banner auftaucht, sondern da gab es mehrere Firmen, die dann erst mal das initiale Jahr der Entwicklung bezahlt haben, also die George und Betty Moore Foundation, also Moore's Law, das ist derjenige, der das mit dem stetigen technologischen Wachstum herausgefunden hat, das Paul Allen Institute for Artificial Intelligence, also einer der Microsoft-Mitgründer, der gerne mal futuristische Projekte finanziert und eine Suchmaschinenfirma namens Google, die dann Geld reingeschmissen haben. Später kam dann noch ein bisschen mehr Geld aus anderen Quellen dazu. Unter anderem gab es einen Preis, der von IBM gewonnen wurde, der dann ans Wikidata-Budget gespendet wurde. Solche Sachen. Und wir haben da halt angefangen, um eine kleine Aufgabe zu lösen, nämlich strukturierte Daten in die Wikipedia reinzukriegen. Und das ist eine Aufgabe, die der Leiter und das Gehirn, der Architekt, der Meta-Entwickler, Danny Vrendedit, schon ein bisschen länger mit sich rumtrog. Ich glaube, 2005 war das, dass er auf einer Wikipedia-Konferenz gesagt hat, strukturierte Daten in der Wikipedia wäre eigentlich eine geile Sache. Und das ist eigentlich auch nicht so problematisch. Jemand, der sich mit der Media-Wiki-Software auskennt, der kann das durchaus mal in zwei Wochen runterhacken. Das hat dann aber länger gedauert als diese zwei Wochen, die er prophezeit hat.
Ja, bevor wir da gleich voll einsteigen, vielleicht noch mal so kurz dieser Wikimedia-Kontext. Also, das wissen wahrscheinlich die meisten. Also es gibt ja Wikipedia, das kennt ja nur wirklich jeder. Das Online-Lexikon und viele wissen, dass es da auch sehr viele Schwester-Projekte gibt, von Victonary über Wiki-Voyage, Wiki-Travel. Ach, Wiki-Travel gehört nicht dazu, genau. Aber entschuldigung, sag mal noch mal kurz ein paar andere. Was haben wir noch? Dann haben wir noch die Comments, wo die ganzen Bilder drin sind, etc. Also das ist alles so über die Zeit gewachsen. Und die Wikimedia Foundation, die hat sich dann so später als unterstützende Organisation dazu gegründet.
Ja, das ganze Geflecht ist irgendwie sehr, also für Leute, die jetzt Organikram-Nords sind, ist das ja ein innerer Piratenparteitag, aber es ist ein bisschen kompliziert. Es gibt einmal diese Wikimedia Foundation, die dieses Movement halt, ja wir sprechen da immer vom Movement, also die Gesamtheit dieser Wikimedia-Projekte unterstützt. Das sind auch letztendlich die, die diese Server betreiben. Also bei diversen Rechtsstreitigkeiten mit Wikipedia, da steht irgendwie Quatsch in der Wikipedia, ist es dann halt immer so, dass man sich an die Wikimedia Foundation in den USA wendet, was auch gewisse Vorteile hat, wenn da in den USA halt irgendwie freedom of speech sehr hoch geschätzt wird, sodass es dann halt entsprechend in dieser Jurisdiktion fällt. Also es ist nicht so, dass Wikimedia Deutschland dann die deutsche Wikipedia betreiben würde, sondern der Betrieb liegt bei dieser Wikimedia Foundation.
Also es gibt... Hat denn Wikimedia Deutschland jetzt ganz was Eigenes, Seperates oder ist es irgendwie eine Tochter von der Wikimedia Foundation? Wie muss man sich das...
Ja, Mischung aus beiden, das macht das halt so schön und übersichtlich. Also es ist ein sogenanntes Chapter, eine nationale Organisation. Und es ist das erste Chapter, das gegründet wurde. Also Anfang der Nullerjahre haben sich ein paar Leute auf dem CCC-Kongress getroffen und haben dann im folgenden Jahr, im Januar, einen Verein gegründet zur Unterstützung der Wikipedia, beziehungsweise der Verein hat den Namen Wikimedia Deutschland e.V., Verein zur Förderung des freien Wissens. Also der Scope ist eigentlich dann noch ein bisschen weiter. Es geht um freies Wissen, das gefördert werden soll. Nicht nur in Form von Lexikon-Artikeln, sondern da gibt es auch eine Abteilung, die sich damit beschäftigt, was politisch gerade im Bereich Urheberrechtsreform oder sowas passiert und wie man da eine Stimme haben kann. Es gibt im Bereich Bildung und Wissen, wo überlegt wird in Form von Workshops, zum Beispiel ganz aktuell, wie man die Diversität in der Wikipedia erhöhen kann oder die Diversität im freien Wissen erhöhen kann, also dass nicht alles wirklich nur von alten weißen Männern erstellt wird, sondern dass da auch verschiedene Perspektiven reinkommen. Das sind so Meta-Arbeiten, wo die meisten Leute gar nicht im Kopf haben, dass das irgendwie noch mit diesem Online-Lexikon zu tun haben sollte, aber das finde ich gerade eine spannende Angelegenheit. Also Wikimedia Deutschland ist eine selbstständige, aber an das Wikimedia-Movement angeschlossene Organisation, ist nicht betreibbar von der Wikipedia, aber über dieses große Fundraising, also Wikipedia lebt ja nicht von Anzeigen, was erstaunlich ist bei einer Webseite, die in den Top 5 weltweit mitspielt. Also da haben sie uns alle irgendwie eine Bezahlung über Anzeigen, sondern lebt davon, dass einmal oder mehrmals im Jahr Spendenaufrufe eingeblendet werden und Leute spenden dann. Typischerweise spenden sie in Deutschland für Wikimedia Deutschland. Und diese Spenden, die reinkommen, werden dann verteilt. Ein Teil davon geht an die Foundation und wird dann zum Betrieb der Server eingesetzt. Ein Teil davon geht an Wikimedia Deutschland.
Um die ganzen Projekte zu fördern. Jetzt scheint ja Deutschland, also es ist ja gesagt, es gibt auch noch andere Chapter, aber Deutschland spielt schon eine besondere Rolle in diesen nächsten Wikimedia-Universen.
Oh ja, kann man wirklich sagen.
Also auch schon von der Media-Wiki-Software waren ja einige Deutsche von Anfang an Mitkernentwickler.
Genau, also diese Phase 2 der Entwicklung von der Media-Wiki-Software wurde tatsächlich von damals noch deutschen Bio-Studenten. Ich hoffe, das stimmt jetzt und das ist nicht Bioinformatik oder Biochemie oder sowas. Sonst entschuldige ich mich bei Magnus Manske, aber ich glaube, er ist Biologie-Student damals gewesen. Mittlerweile ist er natürlich Dozent und lebt auch in Großbritannien. Diese Phase 2 wurde von ihm eingeleitet und dann später wurde es dann halt noch ein bisschen umgeschrieben und umstrukturiert, architiert und so weiter. Aber ja, du hast ganz recht, also dieses Wikimedia Deutschland hat eine große Rolle. Nicht nur, dass es irgendwie das größte Chapter ist, das erste Chapter ist. Ich glaube auch, wenn man da jetzt mit so Stereotypen oder so ankommt, also das trifft einfach so ein bisschen einen deutschen Nerv, also diese Selbsthilfegruppe von Besserwissern im Land der Dichter und Denker und so, das scheint doch sehr attraktiv zu sein.
Ja, ich glaube auch so dieses akribische, strukturierte Datensammeln, das liegt diesem Land auch kulturell irgendwo, ja?
Ja, muss wohl so sein, sonst wäre die Geschichte irgendwie anders verlaufen, ja.
Deutsche Wikipedia war auch lange Zeit, glaube ich, die zweitgrößte, jetzt ist es, nicht mehr, wie ist denn jetzt die zweitgrößte?
Jetzt ist die niederländische Wikipedia die zweitgrößte.
Niederländische, wahrscheinlich, weil die im Gegensatz zu den Deutschen die ganzen Fernsehserien eingepflegt haben.
Ja, tatsächlich hat das auch mit dem Thema unseres Gesprächs ziemlich direkt was zu tun. Also die niederländische Wikipedia hat erst mal sehr gelockerte Relevanzkriterien. Also das ist ja das, was eine große Kritik immer in der deutschen Wikipedia ist, dass da ein Löschwahn herrscht und dass da mit Relevanzkriterien dann –Weihnachten hat vor 2000 Jahren auch niemanden interessiert, was soll das und so –kann man alles einbetten in den Artikel zum Universum und so. Überspitzt gesagt. Ich war auch mal, bevor ich angefangen habe, bei Wikimedia Deutschland ein ganz, ganz harter Verfechter von diesem Inklusionismus und hab gesagt, das ist irgendwie echt kokologisch, was da in der deutschen Wikipedia passiert. Mittlerweile, ich würde nicht sagen, dass ich meine Meinung groß geändert habe, aber zumindest habe ich jetzt verstanden, was das Argument der Gegenseite ist. Es reicht nicht irgendwie, dass du jeden Artikel anlegen kannst, sondern irgendwer muss das dann halt auch pflegen. Und wenn man dann halt wirklich alle Schleusen aufmacht und wirklich jeder Quatsch dann da drin steht, dann ist einfach die Manpower nicht mehr da, um das zu pflegen. Andererseits geht es bei Wikipedien, die die Personalien ein bisschen weniger gut aufgestellt sind, geht es auch mit lockereren Relevanzkriterien. Aber ich glaube, das wird so ein ewiger Streit sein. Ich glaube auch der Höhepunkt dieses Streits ist irgendwie schon lange vorbei. Also da gab es mal viel Stunk und Geschrei im Netz. Mittlerweile hat sich das alles offen einigermaßen erträgliches Level wieder eingependelt. Also die Relevanzkriterien bei der niederländischen Wikipedia sind auf jeden Fall ein bisschen kindgerechter und familienfreundlicher. Da muss man irgendwie nicht wirklich zwei Wochen Kampf in der Löschhülle investieren, um seinen neuen Artikel durchzukriegen. Das ist das eine. Was viel, viel relevanter ist, ist, dass die niederländische Wikipedia einen folgenreichen Beschluss getroffen hat, was das maschinelle Erstellen von Artikeln angeht, sogenannte Bot-Artikel. Deswegen wird es halt als Botpedia von den Gegnern dann auch verschrien. Das heißt, du findest in der niederländischen Wikipedia, aber auch in der schwedischsprachigen Wikipedia, findest du unheimlich viele Artikel, wie der Schmetterling mit diesem lateinischen Namen ist ein Schmetterling der Familie, der dieser lateinischen Namen oder die Gemeinde so und so ist. Eine Gemeinde mit 1500 Einwohnern im...
Eine Birne ist eine Frucht.
Ja, sowas.
Ich bin ja eigentlich auch inkludistisch angehaucht. Und ich hatte ja auch am Anfang dieses Movements sehr viel Berührung damit, war da auch mental involviert. Fühlte mich jetzt nicht so berufend, da gleich organisationell mitzuspielen.
Aber du warst einer, der zumindest Zeitweile ich mal zu den Hauptautoren der Wikipedia gehörte.
Da hatte ich so eine Phase.
Ich, jetzt war vor gar nicht langer Zeit, am Wochenende, war eine Veranstaltung, die Wikikon und das ist halt so das Zusammentreffen der Community der Artikelautoren und da wurde dann irgendwie auch gesagt, ich bin ja schon alter Hase, Urgestein in der Wikipedia, ich bin ja schon seit 2007 dabei und da habe ich auch gedacht, holla, 2007, das ist aber ein ganz schöner Noob eigentlich, der hat das noch nicht gesehen, diese Artikel mit eine Birne ist eine Frucht, Punkt, Ende des Artikels.
Das war, also um das Zitat gleich mal plastisch zu machen, das ist, ich weiß noch, die, ich kann es am Anfang, hat irgendwann mal, ich glaube, das war die französische Wikipedia, hat irgendwie ihren, was war das, den tausendsten oder zehntausendsten Artikel gefeiert und da war das so der Titel der Verlautbarung Pressebetalung, ich weiß nicht mehr ganz genau in welcher Form ihrer Party, weil das so einer der ersten Artikel war in der französischen Wikipedia und ich meine, ich will jetzt nicht zu sehr in diese ganze Wikipedia-Historie einsteigen, aber das finde ich schon auch symptomatisch, so dieses Motto, auch besonders der deutschen Wikipedia war ja am Anfang dieses sei mutig, so heißt ja sogar auch diese Chaosradio-Sendung, die wir irgendwann mal zur Wikipedia gemacht haben.
Ist immer noch ein Motto, ja, auch wenn man jetzt sehr, sehr, sehr viel Mut braucht.
Jetzt muss man besonders mutig sein, aus anderen Gründen, aber sei mutig im Sinne von fang doch einfach mal an zu schreiben, auch wenn da erstmal wenig ist, daraus kann halt viel entstehen und auch so ein simpler Beitrag, so eine Feststellung kann eben schon helfen und irgendwann war natürlich auch dieser Artikel sehr umfangreich und diese Bots machen es ja im Prinzip jetzt an der Stelle genauso, sie setzen eigentlich erstmal so ein bisschen die Saat, ja sagen, okay wir wissen, dass es X gibt und X ist ein Y und jetzt mach doch mal selber weiter.
Und vielleicht noch eine Einwohnerzahl und das war's dann.
Genau, irgendwer muss ja auch mal anfangen.
Ja, genau, es ist halt auch da irgendwie, da gab es eine Diskussion auch zu Bodpedia Pro und Contra und ich bin halt auch mit starken Vorurteilen in die Diskussion reingegangen und bin mit weniger Vorurteilen rausgekommen, also natürlich gibt es auch Argumente gegen sowas, denn wenn du jetzt anfängst, Milliarden von astronomischen Objekten einfach mal in die Wikipedia reinzupumpen, da kannst du von ausgehen, dass da keine richtige Bearbeitung mehr stattfindet. Also da kommen Menschen nicht mehr hinterher, da noch sinnvolle Artikel draus zu stricken. Also das kann es nicht sein, da muss ein anderes Tempo dann vorgelegt werden.
Man kann ja auch sagen, dass wo es nicht einen Menschen gibt, der sozusagen das Gefühl hat, hier müsste auch was darüber geschrieben werden, also mindestens einen, dass dann eben vielleicht die Relevanz auch wirklich nicht gegeben ist, weil dann will es auch keiner nachschlagen.
Ja, aber gerade bei Daten, die in irgendeiner Form strukturiert vorliegt, da lacht einen das dann halt auch richtig an. Also es gab einen Bot, der in der englischen Wikipedia unterwegs ist, der einfach mal alle amerikanischen Gemeinden reingepumpt hat. Und da findet man heute noch irgendwie Reste von diesem Bot. Dass man da irgendwie, weiß ich nicht, Novaville, Minnesota hat so und so viel Einwohner. Liegt im County so und so. Und natürlich ist das mehr als nichts. Und es gab einen hübschen Moment, wo dann jemand so ein Buch, also weißt du, mit Seiten und so, nicht auf dem Kindle oder so, so ein richtig gebundenes Buch hochhielt und sagte, das ist der Volksbrockhaus, ich schlage das mal auf, nehme irgendwie mal einen Artikel raus und so. Das sind alles nur Stubs. Das war früher der Standard in diesen Leksekunden. Also diese Stubs, die Artikel, ich habe da mal was geschrieben, genau, diese ein, zwei Satz Artikel, Suogate oder so was, die dann von Bots angelegt werden, das war früher wirklich der Standard. Also da hattest du dann irgendwie, er hat dann so eine Schweizer Gemeinde vorgelesen, so viel Einwohner hat einen Rheinhaufen. Das stand tatsächlich früher mal so im Leksekund und das war dann die ausreichende Information.
Aber es ist wahrscheinlich auch eine Frage, mit welcher Qualität so was gemacht wird, weil in dem Moment, wo man ja z. B nicht nur sagt, es gibt diesen Ort und er hat so viele Einwohner, sondern auch noch sagt, er liegt im Landkreis sowieso und auch dieser Landkreis wird dann vielleicht auch noch mit dazu angelegt. Dann bildet man ja auch diese ganze Hierarchie quasi, die solchen Informationen innewohnen schon mal ab und kann sich daran orientieren.
Genau und was man dann auch hat bei einem Wiki oder überhaupt bei Hypertext-Dokumenten ist dann halt die Links wo du dann halt beliebig tief reingehen kannst. Das fand ich eine interessante Sache, dass da vor einem anderen Vortrag, da ging es um Diversität und da berichtete eine Frau, die, ich glaube, beim Frauencomputerzentrum hier in Berlin arbeitet und unter anderem, oder vielleicht bringe ich es auch durcheinander, es war jemand anders, es ging um ein Projekt mit Leuten mit Migrationshintergrund und da vor allen Dingen dann die Mütter, die alle gesagt haben, ja, was so Tagespolitik angeht, da lese ich sehr gerne in der Wikipedia. Denn wenn ich auf Spiegel Online oder so gehe, dann wird sehr viel vorausgesetzt, bei der Wikipedia kann ich halt dann durch diese Hyperlinks immer so weiterklicken und wenn ich was nicht verstehe, dann klicke ich auf den Link und kann mich da in den Aspekt noch einlesen und dann plötzlich verstehe ich dann, worum es eigentlich geht.
Also wie man es dreht und wendet, auf jeden Fall entwickelt sich das alles weiter. Und abgesehen davon, dass jetzt über so einen langen Zeitraum, ich weiß nicht, wie lange gibt es die Wikipedia jetzt schon? Zehn Jahre sind rum.
2002, glaube ich, aus der Taufe gehoben. Und der Boom kam so 2004. Also da gab es erstmal eine Erwähnung im Spiegel. Und wer danach gekommen ist, der ist eigentlich Outsider.
Aber das hat sich ja auch früher abgezeichnet. Wenn man das so gesehen hat, wie sich das entwickelt hat, schnell kamen so diese Sidebars auf. So diese, wie heißen die korrekt in der Wikipedia?
Diese Infoboxen?
Infoboxen, genau, richtig. Also wo man dann angefangen hat zu sagen, ja, okay, wenn es eine Stadt ist, dann gibt es diese und jene Information, die will man eigentlich immer schnell haben. Vorwahl, Postleitzahl, Landkreis etc. Man erwartet quasi eine gewisse Grundinformation, die eben bei einem Artikel über einen bestimmten Typ von Information immer wieder da ist. Und das ist halt über lange Zeit manuell gepflegt worden, grafisch immer wieder modifiziert und verbessert worden.
Das manuell pflegen, das ist eigentlich unfassbar, was Leute in ihrer Freizeit manuell an stupiden Kleinigkeiten machen, das in Kategorien einsortieren, diese ganzen Infoboxen. Dann aktuell halten und vor allen Dingen, also das ist für mich das Unfassbarste gewesen, immer die ganze Zeit abgleichen, wie heißt dieser Artikel in einer anderen Sprache und das dann in den Artikel reinschreiben, damit es dann in einer anderen Seitenleiste unter dieser Artikel in einer anderen Sprache auftaucht.
Ja genau, dann ändert sich so eine Information mal. Vor kurzem wurden ja die Ergebnisse der Volkszählungen hier in Deutschland präsentiert und auf einmal war der Erkenntnisstand darüber, wie es sich denn mit der Einwohnerzahl in verschiedenen Gemeinden verhält. Dann lag alles neu vor, das wird sich dann in der deutschen Wikipedia schnell durchgesetzt haben. Nur was ist dann mit den anderen?
Genau, da gibt es ja noch 218 andere Sprachen.
218?
Ich glaube, das ist die Zahl, ja. Also auf jeden Fall über 200. Könnte auch 208 sein. Okay, ihr könnt das alles in der Wikipedia nachgucken. Also über 200 Sprachprojekte, die halt unterschiedlich gut aufgestellt sind. Also die ganzen großen Sprachen, da wird das dann auch irgendwie funktionieren, dass man das überträgt. Aber was ist mit den ganzen kleinen Sprachen? Also in den afrikanischen Sprachen ist Wikipedia gar nicht so abgehoben, wie man sich das vorgestellt hat. Da passiert nicht sonderlich viel, da ist einfach das Potenzial sehr, sehr klein. Oder es gibt einfach Sprachen, die eine extrem kleine Sprecherzahl haben und wo Wikipedia dann halt auch zum Teil zur Sprachpflege eingesetzt wird. Das ist dann halt deren Lexikon. Früher hätte das niemand gewagt, irgendwie ein Lexikon zu drucken für occidental. Das ist eine Sprache, die im Süden von Frankreich, in der Nähe von Spanien gesprochen wird. Früher mal Provençal hieß, Provençalisch. Da wäre einfach der Markt nicht dafür da gewesen, aber die Sprecher dieser Sprache beteiligen sich irgendwie sehr enthusiastisch. Oder sorbisch hier in Deutschland auch. Es gibt zwei sorbische Wikipedien, für niedersorbisch und obersorbisch, weil das ja auch unterschiedliche Sprachen sind.
Ja, und was natürlich dann auch man sich dann denkt, jetzt sind hier so viele Informationen zusammengetragen worden, wie kriege ich die wieder raus, wenn ich jetzt mal eine Statistik machen will, wenn ich mal eine irgendwie geartete Analyse betreiben möchte. Das sind dann so Überlegungen, die dann auch letztlich in dieses Wikidata-Projekt gemündet haben. Vielleicht kannst du das mal so ein bisschen zusammenfassen. Was waren denn sozusagen die Auslöser, die Probleme oder die Opportunitäten, die sich da angeboten haben, dass die Leute gesagt haben, wir müssen da mal was machen?
Na, da hast du jetzt schon irgendwie sehr viel wichtiges an Fragestellungen angesprochen. Also auf der einen Seite möchte man gerne so einen automatischen Abgleich haben für gewisse Daten, wo sich das anbietet. Also dass halt Einwohnerzahlen dann halt vielleicht sogar bei Wikipedien, wo nicht entsprechende Manpower da ist, automatisch angepasst werden, aus irgendeiner zentralen Datenquelle kommen. Das ist das eine, dass man gerne eine zentrale Datenquelle für...
Also dass die Einwohnerzahl für Berlin nicht in die deutsche Wikipedia reinschreibe und mich dann nachmittag hinsetze und das in 218 anderen auch noch korrigiere, sondern dass man nur einen Ort hat, wo man das reinschreibt.
Zum Beispiel. Und dann können die anderen Projekte halt sagen, irgendwie wir holen das direkt aus diesem Ort oder...
Wir haben zumindest eine Referenz dafür.
Wir haben zumindest eine Referenz, genau. Das ist das eine. Das andere ist dann genau den Weg, den du auch beschrieben hast, das Umgekehrte. Es ist unheimlich viel Information in den Wikipedien drin, die man überhaupt nicht abfragen kann. Also eine Idee oder so eine Art Mem, ein Spruch, ein Ziel, das wir uns gesetzt haben, ist, dass man irgendwie eine Liste, also automatisch generieren sollte, gib mir die 100 größten Städte der Welt mit weiblichen Bürgermeister. Eine Information, die in der Wikipedier irgendwie auch drinsteht, so das ist eine Stadt mit dieser Einwohnerzahl, Bürgermeister ist so und so. Wenn man dann auf den Bürgermeisterartikel klickt, dann sieht man, oh, okay, weiblich.
Ich meine, es gibt ja Listenartikel schon immer, aber die sind ja auch immer dann manuell angelegt worden von Leuten, die der Meinung sind, so eine Liste wäre ja mal toll.
Genau.
Das ist naheliegend, so was weiß ich, die größten Flüsse der Welt.
Das ist naheliegend, es gibt sehr spezielle Listen. Es gibt die List of wartime crossdressers. Es gibt List of inventors killed by their own inventions. List of animals with fraudulent diplomas. Also Tiere, die zu Unrecht einen Universitätsabschluss bekommen haben. Solche Sachen. Das wird wahrscheinlich auch auf die Dauer eher von Hand gepflegt werden, so in einigen Fällen, aber was du sagst, hier die größten Flüsse und Regierungs-, oder wie heißt das, Einheiten von Indien oder sowas, welche Bundesländer, welche Provinzen und so weiter, das würde sich wirklich anbieten, das automatisch irgendwie zu machen.
Ja, wobei es diese Listen ja dann auch meistens in wohlgepflegter Form gibt, aber die sind dann immer sehr eindimensional. Es ist quasi immer nur so eine Sortierung von vielleicht einem oder maximal zwei Kriterien, also so ein primäres Ausschlusskriterium und dann noch so ein paar, naja, bei uns interessiert aus dieser Reihe nur der Aspekt so. Und wenn es dann komplizierter wird?
Naja, also da wird auch viel per Hand gemacht, da bin ich immer überrascht über diese Fleißarbeit, die da in der Community gemacht wird. Natürlich gibt es auch Listen von Listen und mehrere davon, sodass es auch schon Listen von Listen von Listen gibt. Alles irgendwie durchklickbar, aber das ist eigentlich keine Arbeit für Menschen, das ist eine Arbeit für Maschinen, würde ich mal sagen. Und da haben sich auch schon früh dann irgendwelche Forscher dran gemacht, solche Sachen in irgendeiner Form rauszuextrahieren. Also gibt es ein Projekt namens DBpedia, was da auf jeden Fall zu nennen ist. Genau, die versucht haben durch Parsing einfach diese Informationen aus der Wikipedia rauszulutschen und in irgendeine semantische Relation zu setzen. Also wenn in der Infobox was steht oder bestimmte Formulierungen wie Stadt X hat so und so viele Einwohner, dann haben sie das irgendwie versucht in eine Relation zu setzen, um dann ja aus den wichtigsten Artikeln der Wikipedia so was wie ein Gerüst zu bauen. Also tatsächlich eine Sammlung von Daten, die in der Wikipedia vorhanden sind. Auch das wieder ein Projekt, was irgendwie sehr maßgeblich aus Deutschland vorangetrieben worden ist. Und das Wikidata Projekt ist mit den DBpedia Leuten auch sehr freundschaftlich verbunden. Also eine Zeit lang hat eine Mitarbeiterin von DBpedia dann auch im Wikidata-Team gearbeitet. Das war so der eine Strang, wo man auf jeden Fall schon viel interessante Sachen machen konnte. Datenbank-Abfragen und Sachen in Relation setzen. Das war allerdings alles mit handgeklöppelten Parsern und immer der Versuch von natürlicher Sprachverarbeitung tritt irgendwann an seine Grenzen und so. Dann steht dann vielleicht auch Quatsch drin, obwohl sie sehr beeindruckende Ergebnisse hatten.
Aber das hat dann wahrscheinlich schon mal interessante Ergebnisse geliefert, bezüglich Fragestellungen wie, was will man eigentlich wissen, welche Art von Abbildungen sollen entstehen oder werden benötigt?
Ja, also DBpedia wird auch im Forschungsbereich sehr intensiv eingesetzt. Der ganze Fokus liegt auch wirklich auf diesem wissenschaftlichen Bereich, wo viele Leute einer Religion, Glaubensrichtung folgen, die unter dem Namen das semantische Web bekannt ist. So, die Älteren werden sich erinnern. Das war früher mal die Idee, dass im Internet nicht einfach nur HTML-Seiten veröffentlicht werden, sondern dass über sogenannte Triples dann halt auch Aussagen über die Verknüpfung der Inhalte gemacht werden. Ein ganz großer Traum, den Tim Berners-Liedern auch mitgeträumt hat, also der Erfinder des WWW, dass man in irgendeiner Art und Weise semantische Aussagen über das macht, worum es in dieser Seite geht. Das wurde mit einer relativ komplizierten Beschreibungssprache gemacht. Das Resource Description Framework. Genau, das ist RDF.
Sehr nördig.
Wo man dann, ja, Ontologien und so, also es geht dann wirklich in den philosophischen Bereich rein. Also die Welt ist alles, was der Fall ist und worüber reden wir eigentlich und solche Sachen. Aber es ist ein aktiv beforschtes Feld, wo ich auch viel zu wenig darüber weiß. Aber da wird intensiveres gemacht. Und da gibt es auch schon so Ansätze wie eine Abfragesprache für semantische Daten namens Sparkle, S-P-A-R-Q-L. Und mit einem Sparkle Endpoint könnte man dann halt beliebige semantische Relationen zueinander verknüpfen und dann Abfragen bekommen. Das skaliert nur bis zu einem bestimmten Punkt und zwingt bei einer Datenbasis wie Wikipedia sicherlich irgendwie die meisten Server, die man so für Geld kaufen kann, in die Knie. Das ist einfach noch sehr viel Science-Fiction, auch wenn, wie gesagt, die Angehörigen dieser Religion des semantischen Webstars anders reden würden und sagen würden, nein, die reine Lehre ist es schon, alles in RDF-Trippeln zu schreiben und per Sparkle abzufragen. Ja, das wäre eigentlich, wenn wir jetzt wirklich im Uni-Elfenbeinturm uns befinden würden und Papers veröffentlichen, die halt, außer den Professoren, die unsere Arbeit betreuen, eigentlich sonst niemand mehr liest oder verstehen kann, dann wäre das wahrscheinlich die Art und Weise, wie Wikidata aufgebaut worden wäre. Aber wir hatten ja irgendwie dann eine sehr, sehr große Community zu betreuen, von denen viele gar nicht Informatik studiert haben oder diesen Spezialgebiet, dieses Spezialgebiet der Ontologien und systematischen Webs irgendwie verstehen.
Ich glaube schon den Begriff Ontologie kennt fast keiner.
Ja, also das ist die Wissenschaft von der Ordnung der Dinge sozusagen.
Von der Ordnung der Dinge, schön gesagt.
Ja, also DBpedia gab es und es gab von Denny und Markus, die diesen folgenreichen Vortrag mit, in zwei Wochen sollte das eigentlich in MediaWiki gehackt werden, dann könnte man irgendwie semantische, strukturierte Daten in Wikipedia haben. Da gab es dann halt auch ein Projekt, wo sie sich mit beschäftigt haben und das sollte dem einen oder anderen vielleicht mal über den Weg gelaufen sein, Semantik MediaWiki, SMW, was relativ häufig eingesetzt wird. Also ganz gerne übrigens auch bei Firmen als Knowledge Base, wo ich dann in der Seite dann auch...
Das ist ein Derivat von MediaWiki, von der Wikipedia-Software.
Es ist MediaWiki plus eine ganze Latte an Extensions, die du dann drauf packst und dann hast du ein semantisches MediaWiki.
Okay, also kein Fork der Software, sondern man benutzt einfach das normale MediaWiki, was auch weiterentwickelt wird und die Extensions machen dann daraus eine semantische Variante.
Und da waren viele interessante Aspekte drin, die halt auch wirklich eine Lücke gefüllt haben, die MediaWiki vorher nicht füllen konnte. Also vorher, naja, du konntest halt wirklich sagen, worum geht es bei dieser Seite, was ist das, was ist das für ein Datentyp und relativ schnell kam dann etwas dazu, dass sich Semantic Forms nannte, dass du halt gesagt hast, auf dieser Seite sollen ja nur Inhalte von bestimmten Datentypen eingetragen werden und deswegen generiere ich dir on the fly ein Eingabeformular dafür.
Das gab es ja auch schon ganz früh am Anfang, das erste, womit ich gearbeitet habe, als ich so in die Wikipfalle geraten bin, das war ja T-Wiki, das kennst du sicherlich auch noch. So ein Perl geschrieben und auch ganz interessant wegweisend war, was so Namespaces und so Trennung von Bereichen betrifft und auch genau diese Formularsache war da mit drin, damit ich auch mal eine Weile mit gearbeitet habe. Es hatte dann andere Probleme wie zum Beispiel so unsägliche alte Wiki-Camel-Case-Syntax, die bestenfalls im Englischen funktioniert, aber meiner Meinung nach auch da nicht. Und das heißt, Semantik MediaWiki hat solche Ideen dann da aufgegriffen und das normale MediaWiki quasi per Extension einfließen lassen.
Genau. Ich weiß nicht, wann dieser Podcast veröffentlicht wird, aber vielleicht steht dann ja noch der Kongress vor der Tür. Genau.
Also der 30C3.
Genau, der 30C3 steht dann vor der Tür. Also wir befinden uns jetzt im Jahr 2013 für die Hörer aus der Zukunft. Und die Webseite vom Kongress basiert komplett auf Semantik-Media-Wiki, sodass man dann halt so Sachen anlegen kann wie Geldautomaten um das Kongressgebäude, Restaurants oder auch so Sachen wie diese Assemblies, wo sich dann Leute zusammenfinden. Die Benutzerseiten sind halt auch gleich dann mit Semantik-Formen bearbeitbar, sodass du dann sagen kannst, hier, das ist mein Hacker-Space und das ist meine Telefonnummer und so weiter. Und in diesen einzelnen Feldern dann wirklich nur bestimmte Datentypen erlaubt sind. Und das wird dann automatisch dann in Wikitext rausgerennert. Und vor allen Dingen der Punkt ist, dass diese Information dann auch verknüpfbar bleibt, sodass ich mir dann relativ schnell eine Liste aller deutschsprachigen Kongressbesucher zusammenklicken kann. Oder ja, alle, was weiß ich, Restaurants mit dieser Küchenauswahl oder sowas, wenn das schon aufgenommen wird. Also man kann sich da auch sehr schnell verlieren in den Datentypen, aber...
Zumindest schafft es eine eingeschränkte Maschine. Also ist es schon maschinenlesbar dadurch oder ist es einfach nur mehr ein strukturiertes Erfassen von Informationen, sodass man den Leuten jetzt nicht aber Millionen von Konventionen beibringen muss, weil es relativ klar ist, wie man jetzt etwas einzugeben hat?
Es ist auch maschinenlesbar. Also MediaWiki hat immer auch eine API dabei und ist immer für Maschinen auch gedacht.
Aber man konnte ja... In dem normalen MediaWiki kriegt man ja quasi nur diesen Wiki-Source, also das, was man auch so editiert. Wenn man sagt Edit, dann hat man halt diese ganze Wolke mit eckigen Klammern vor der Nase.
Ja, das wird auch in diesem Wikitext umgesetzt. Da stehen dann halt auch die Werte dann.
Okay, das ist dann quasi die Ergänzung, die das Symantec MediaWiki macht. Also Symantec MediaWiki nimmt eigentlich jetzt von dem Urcharakter nichts weg, sondern schafft eigentlich nur eine strukturierte Erfassung und damit auch eine strukturierte Ablage, aber innerhalb einer normalen Wikiseite.
Für große Organisationen, für Firmen oder Chaos Computer Clubs oder sowas ist das halt ein total tolles Ding, weil du auf einmal wirklich eine Knowledge Base machen kannst, wo du dann halt auch irgendwie Abfragen drauf machen kannst. Und ja, Danny hat da wirklich was Tolles mit geschaffen. Danny und seine Mitstreiter, also Markus Kreutz ist da noch zu nennen. Und jetzt sehr, sehr aktiv bei Wikidata ist unser Kollege Jörn aus Belgien, der unheimlich viel Code einfach raushaut und sehr, sehr aktiv ist bei Symantec MediaWiki. Die ganze Kiste ist halt auch so erfolgreich, dass es neben diesen ganzen MediaWiki-Konferenzen halt eine eigene Symantec MediaWiki-Konferenz zweimal im Jahr gibt, die dann in Kalifornien, in Köln und so weiter stattfinden. Und wo eine interessante Mischung aus einerseits Symantec Webforschern, andererseits MediaWiki-Hackern und dann auch sehr, sehr häufig Leute aus, weiß ich nicht, großen Logistikunternehmen, die einfach wahnsinnig viel interne Knowledge Base verwalten wollen und Symantec MediaWiki einsetzen, da zusammenkommen und Vorträge anhören und halten.
Und da ist auch die Lernkurve überschaubar, nehme ich mal an.
Ja, aber sie ist doch relativ hoch. Also du musst eigentlich schon sehr viel über Datenstrukturen und sowas wissen. Zumindest fürs Anlegen des Ganzen ist es nicht so einfach, dass du... Also da musst du schon relativ Gehirnschmalz haben.
Sage ich es anders. Wenn man jemanden hat, der das anlegen kann, dann ist die Lernkurve für die, die das, was dann angelegt wurde, die das benutzen sollen, relativ niedrig?
Genau. Das ist dann sogar ein vereinfachtes Wiki, würde ich sagen. Und ich denke mal, das Semantik-Media-Wiki, auf jeden Fall sowas wie Urvater von dem ist, was wir jetzt mit Wikidata machen, aber aus diversen Gründen, war uns das immer noch zu kompliziert und immer noch zu akademisch und immer noch nicht snappy auf den Punkt, dass wir einfach nur strukturierte Daten in einen Wiki reingebracht haben.
Fällt dir da was ein, was da jetzt das Problem war bei Semantik oder das Problem ist bei Semantik Media Wiki?
Da müsste man sehr, sehr in Details gehen, aber erstmal wird bei jeder Neuerfindung das Rad auch immer ein bisschen runder. Also es war auch mal Zeit, das alles nochmal in Reihen aufzubauen. Dann hatte sich halt auch das Web ein bisschen weiterentwickelt. Also was so User Interfaces angeht, war auch so ein bisschen ein anderer Anspruch mittlerweile durch diese ganzen Ajax-Spielereien, Autocompletion und sonst was.
Und das ist ja auch etwas, was sich quasi nur in einem Wiki abspielt. Also wenn ich das jetzt auf Wikipedia denke, dann würde ich Semantik Media Wiki als Extension mit in die deutsche Wikipedia reinmachen. Da würde dann irgendwas erfasst werden, dann wäre die Information ja auch nach wie vor nur da.
Das ist ein Punkt, dass ich halt eigentlich ein Repository für strukturierte Daten habe, was für alle über 200 Sprachversionen halt zugreifbar ist. Und das macht es halt auch schwierig. Also das fängt dann schon an mit, wie benenne ich eigentlich diese Daten, diese Items, um die es eigentlich geht?
Ja, Sprachproblematik.
Also da kann man halt irgendwie ganz kulturempirialistisch hingehen und sagen, Englisch, das ist die Sprache und unsere Items heißen auf Englisch und die anderen müssen das dann halt übersetzen. Aber ist vielleicht für so ein internationales Movement, was halt auch dann sagt, wir wollen divers sein und letztendlich sind uns die Kleinen genauso wichtig wie die Großen, vielleicht nicht die richtige Herangehensweise?
Ja, ich meine, Englisch mag erfolgreich sein, aber es ist nicht die meistgesprochene Sprache auf diesem Planeten.
Sodass wir dann einfach gedacht haben, was wir wirklich brauchen, sind zwei Teile. Ein Repository, also ein Repo, ein Wikidata-Repo und dann ganz, ganz viele Clients, die auf dieses Repo zugreifen. Und dann haben wir einen zentralen Punkt. Von dort aus dann die einzelnen Wikipedien-Daten sich herziehen können. Und dieser Client ist dann halt, all das ist auch wieder realisiert in einer Extension für MediaWiki. Also natürlich bauen wir da halt auf die Code-Basis auf, die irgendwie sehr gut gepflegt wird und mittlerweile auch super strenge Qualitätskontrollen hat. Ja, und wir haben das dann halt als Extension realisiert.
Für MediaWiki. Also genauso wie das auch Semantik-MediaWiki gemacht hat.
Aber die Idee war wirklich ein Repository für alles, worum es in der Welt geht, zu haben. Und nicht zu sagen, wir machen jetzt jede Wikipedia zu einem Semantik-Media-Wiki, wo dann sprachabhängig irgendwelche Konventionen über die Semantik irgendwie angefühlt werden, sondern wir trennen das halt. Und wir machen ein neues Projekt, was nicht so häufig vorkommt im Wikimedia-Universum.
Da hat man das Gefühl, schon wieder ein Monat rum, muss mal wieder ein neues Wikimedia-Projekt anstarten.
Genau. Da gab es viele Sachen, die einiges davon hat sich auch durchgesetzt und hat auch sehr bereichert. Aber es gibt auch sehr, sehr kleine Projekte. Also Wikispecies, der Aufbau von einer strukturierten Datenbank für biologische Daten, um diesen Baum des Lebens quasi abzustellen mit Gattungen und Familie und so weiter. Das ist zum Beispiel ein Projekt, wo ich glaube, irgendwie weniger Leute insgesamt daran arbeiten, als Wikimedia Deutschland Mitarbeiter hat. Also das sind halt so knapp 50 Leute, die Wikispecies, ein sehr, sehr kleines Schwesterprojekt, befüllen. Es gibt große Dinge. Wiktionary hat sicherlich noch eine große Community. Commons findet man unheimliche Schätze. Und Wikinews zum Beispiel gibt es auch. Hat nicht ganz so abgehoben, dieser Bürgerjournalismus, wie einige sich das vielleicht erhofft haben, aber existiert noch als Projekt. Aber nach dieser Phase, wo du sagst, dass irgendwie jede Woche ein neues Wikimedia-Projekt hat sich das dann auch alles ein bisschen erholt, sodass Wikidata jetzt auch seit sechs Jahren das erste neue Projekt war. Also es ist jetzt im Moment nicht das neueste, denn seit kurzem gibt es halt noch einen freien Reiseführer, Wikivoyage. Aber da war erstmal eine lange Pause, weil man gedacht hat, jetzt noch ein neues Projekt oder sowas, aber Wikidata ist dann schon unterschiedlich genug, um ein neues Wikimedia-Projekt zu rechtfertigen.
Dieses Wikispecies und auch Wiktionary, das sind ja eigentlich ganz gute Beispiele von Wikis, die eigentlich einen extremen Datenbankcharakter in sich schon haben, wo es eigentlich fast ausschließlich nur um mehr oder weniger logische Aussagen geht.
Und wo eigentlich auch die Wikisoftware für was benutzt wird, wo es vielleicht nicht unbedingt für geeignet ist.
Ja, wo man sich wahrscheinlich auch als Autor natürlich auch fragen muss, wenn ich jetzt hier was in Wikispecies eintrage und da so die Energie einbringe, dass es da richtig drin steht, dann ist es damit in der normalen Wikipedia nicht drin, aber da ist ja diese Information genauso erforderlich, weil man ja sagen muss, dieser Vogel ist ein aus der Gattung tralala und die Art ist blalala. Also man doppelt eigentlich die Information.
Richtig. Ja, und auch wenn ich immer wieder überrascht bin, was die Leute so an Massenkollaborationen in ihrer Freizeit machen, irgendwann ist dann auch mal Schluss. Du kannst nicht beliebig viele Aufgaben auf Freiwillige aufteilen. Speziell, wenn du dann noch das gleichzeitig lokalisiert in über 200 Sprachen haben möchtest.
Jetzt ist Wikidata dann irgendwann mal als Projekt auch was geworden. Hat dann nicht zwei Wochen gedauert.
Und war auch nicht im Jahr 2005, sondern später.
Was hat denn dann letztlich den Ausschlag gegeben, dass dann auch wirklich gestartet wurde? Also was musste denn passieren? Was war denn letzten Endes so der Katalysator, der dann dazu geführt hat, dass man sagt, okay, jetzt muss es auch sein? Weil die Probleme zu groß wurden?
Na die Probleme wurden jetzt nicht sonderlich größer, aber die waren halt von Anfang an auch wirklich absehbar. Irgendeine Form von strukturierten Daten hätten wir gerne in der Wikipedia. Wahrscheinlich musste das einfach nur so reifen. Und es war dann irgendwann der Zeitpunkt gekommen. Und dann hieß es einfach sei mutig. Und dann wurde sich um Drittmittel bemüht und dieses Team zusammengestellt. Vielleicht hätte das auch noch ein paar Jahre schlummern können und die Leute hätten einfach Angst gehabt anzufangen. Aber ich bin froh, dass es einfach mal gemacht wurde.
Was ist denn jetzt sozusagen dabei rausgekommen? Was ist das jetzt, worauf man sich festgelegt hat? Wir hatten jetzt viele Beispiele, wo schon mal was versucht wurde. So von dem reinen Wiki-Ansatz, Wiktionary, Wiki Species. Das hat alles irgendwie seine Endlichkeit gefunden. Die Versuche, aus dem, was reingeschrieben wurde, Datenbanken zu erzeugen, also diese DB-Pedia-Projektansatz, dann eben dieses, lass uns zumindest die strukturierten Daten mit in das Wiki reinmachen, damit es eben so was wie DB-Pedia es einfacher hat, sprich, dieses Semantik-Media-Wiki, mit der Problematik, dass es dann halt auch immer nur in einem Wiki ist und man eben diese Kollaboration über mehrere Sprachwikis hinweg nicht so ohne Weiteres machen kann. Wie lautet dir dann sozusagen der Beschluss, was denn stattdessen zu machen ist?
Ja, also aus zwei Richtungen gab es dann erstmal den Beschluss. Einmal, wir wollen eine neue Software schreiben, die die Grundlage dafür sein soll, und wir wollen ein neues Projekt, also eine neue Community haben. Und diese Community und dieses Projekt nennen wir Wikidata. Hat dann auch so eine fancy Headline. Ja, das Repository für freies Wissen oder die freie Datenbank, die von jedem bearbeitet werden kann, bzw. auf Englisch ist es noch schöner, that can be edited by machines and people alike. Also das ist eine ganz nette Grundregel des Projektes, dass wir einerseits sehr freundlich eingestellt sind gegenüber Bots und programmierbaren Importeuren von Daten in strukturierter Form. Also Programmen, die einfach mal so einen Datenbankdump in Wikidata reinhauen wollen, was in Wikipedia dann halt irgendwie Diskussionen führt, weil es nicht wirklich das ist, wie Artikelautoren normalerweise arbeiten. Aber hier ist es extrem angemessen. Auf der einen Seite wollen wir halt auch ein Interface haben, was Menschen, die auf diese Seite kommen, wirklich ermöglicht, auf einen Blick zu sehen, okay, das steht da, das fehlt noch. Ich klicke jetzt mal auf diesen Knopf und trag diese Information nach.
Also dieses einfache, ich kann es selber ändern. Jeder kann dazu beitragen, der Grundgedanke.
Und diese Mischung hat sich als extrem fruchtbar gezeigt. Sowohl Maschinen als auch Menschen da halt an diesem freien...
Das ist im Prinzip eigentlich auch schon so, dass die Erfolgsgeschichte der ursprünglichen Wikipedia gewesen ist. Dass es einfach geschafft hat, mit der Software so den richtigen Mittelweg zwischen Kanten ordentlich Hypertext ausgeben, sodass sich das dann liest. Und wenn man es bearbeiten will, ist die Zugänglichkeit zumindest nicht komplett unzumutbar.
Genau, also passt auf jeden Fall ganz gut in diese Grundphilosophie rein.
Aber trotzdem sowas wie spitze Klammern, eckige Klammern, Gewitter irgendwo reinzuschreiben, um das zu erzeugen, das war dann aber nicht der Lösungsansatz.
Ja, also bei Wikidata ist das größtenteils unnötig, da jetzt noch eine eigene Syntax sich auszudenken, denn wir haben es meistens mit ganz einfachen Fällen zu tun, dass ich halt irgendwie in sehr vielen Fällen einfach ein Property und ein Value habe, also so eine Paarrelation. Und da kann ich dann einfach Textfelder machen, wo dann mit Autocompletion und Schnick Schnack und so das dann gemacht wird. Also da jetzt noch mal eine eigene Syntax draufzubauen. Also für diejenigen, die sich früh schon mit dem Web beschäftigt haben, ist diese Wikisyntax ja wirklich eine Vereinfachung.
Ja, im Vergleich zu HTML.
Genau, finden wir alle ganz toll. Mittlerweile habe ich schon gemerkt, ja, die Welt ist auch weitergegangen und das Internet ist auch größer geworden. Es sind ganz viele neue, interessante Leute ins Internet gekommen, die das schrecklich finden, was diese Wikisyntax angeht und denen das immer noch zu kompliziert ist und auch zu recht kompliziert ist.
Ja, die Ortswahl haben wir auch schon ganz andere Realität treffen im Web. Diese Web 2.0-Bewegung hat ja das auch alles sehr viel erfahrbarer gemacht. Die Interaktion mit Webseiten ist einfacher und selbstverständlicher geworden. Mittlerweile wundert man sich schon, wenn man irgendwo etwas eingibt und auf einen Button drückt und die Seite lädt neu, das war am Anfang irgendwie der Standard. Und jetzt schaut man schon so leicht verstört.
Genau, und auch so Sachen wie, dass ich dann tatsächlich irgendwie, ja, weiß ich nicht, Anführungszeichen oder drei Anführungszeichen setzen muss, um irgendwas fett zu machen, anstatt dass ich das einfach markiere und oben irgendwie im Editor sage, auf Bolt klicke und so. Also da gibt es auch Leute, die dran arbeiten. Es gibt den Visual Editor, der zum Teil schon auf der Wikipedia sichtbar ist. Ganz großes Software-Projekt jetzt aus San Francisco von der Wikimedia Foundation, was ziemlich viel umkrempeln wird. Also da wirst du dann auch wirklich in der Wikipedia arbeiten, wie in einer anständigen Textverarbeitung, inklusive. Einfach mal so Bilder umschieben, die auf Comments liegen und Infoboxen, die sich on the fly generieren und so weiter. Eventuell dann auch befüllt mit strukturierten Daten, die aus Wikidata kommen. Da bleibt die Entwicklung auch nicht stehen. Aber ich habe es zum Beispiel gesehen, es gibt ein Projekt bei Wikimedia Deutschland namens Silberwissen, wo Senioren an Wikipedia herangeführt werden. Die meisten sind ja nicht nur weiß, männlich, akademisch, die in der Wikipedia schreiben, sondern auch noch relativ jung. Ab Mitte 40 ist dann irgendwie auch Schluss. Das ist ja auch eine sehr eingeschränkte Perspektive auf das Ganze. Deswegen war die Idee dann speziell für Senioren, die zum Teil geschichtlich oder in irgendwelchen Spezialbereichen unheimliches Wissen haben und halt auch entsprechende Freizeit einfach mal zu Wikipedia-Authoren werden zu.
Man hat auch immer das Gefühl gehabt, so alles, was so von 1990 passiert ist, so spätestens ab 1980, wenn es jetzt nicht gerade so Welterbe wie Beatles ist, das findet da auch nicht so richtig statt.
Ja, es ist hoffentlich ein bisschen besser geworden.
Ja, es ist besser geworden. Aber es war auf jeden Fall lange Zeit, merkte man, da ist so ein Ereignishorizont über den, dass irgendwie alles nicht hinwegkommt und das ändert sich natürlich jetzt langsam.
Und bei diesem Silberwissen-Projekt war das halt auch wirklich, also die Leute haben halt irgendwie auf den Edit-Button geklickt und haben irgendwie eine Mondsprache präsentiert bekommen, wo sie irgendwie wirklich gar nichts mit anfangen konnten.
Verständlich. Ja, aber wie seid ihr da jetzt rangegangen? Ich meine, wie denkt man dann über so was nach? Wenn man auf der einen Seite superkomplexe Aussagen über irgendwelche Objekte haben will, dass ich ja so totale Datenbank denke. Wir hatten das ja schon mit diesem Semantik-Web und dieses RDF, was auch so ein bisschen daran gescheitert ist, dass es einfach so verkopft war, dass man da irgendwann einfach nicht mehr normal denken kann. Aber auf der anderen Seite auch solche Zielgruppen mit einladen will.
Ich finde das Interface relativ snappy geworden und verständlich.
Beschreib mal, was kann man denn da nun eintragen?
Was schreibt man da rein? Erstmal geht es bei Wikidata um Items, um Datenobjekte. Um ein Wissensgegenstand. Ein Wissensgegenstand ist definiert als irgendwas, was in irgendeiner Wikipedia vorhanden ist, weil es sich im Wikimedia-Universum bewegt. Das ist dann entsprechend relevant. Diese Items, diese Wissensgegenstände, die hatten wir eben kurz noch drauf angesprochen, jetzt die einfach auf Englisch zu benennen, wäre halt eine Katastrophe. Also haben die einfach eine Zahlenkolonne. Also sie werden einfach durchnummeriert. Das Wissen der Welt wird durchnummeriert, da abgelegt. Und das fängt dann bei den Items immer an mit Q und dann kommt eine Zahl. Anhand von diesem Q sehe ich bei Wikidata, dass wir jetzt auf einer Seite sind, wo es um ein Item geht, um einen Wissensgegenstand. Wir machen jetzt hier CRE-Folge 205, richtig? Und wenn ich dann bei Wikidata eingebe Q205, dann sehe ich, auf dieser Seite geht es um die Unendlichkeit.
Infinity, wow.
Das siehst du jetzt, weil du die englische Sprachversion eingestellt hast. Aber ganz oben auf der Seite gibt es auch noch eine Auswahl. Wenn du eingeloggt bist, dann kannst du dann auch eine andere Sprache auswählen. Für die anonymen User ist das nicht so mit der Sprachauswahl. Das ist vielleicht auch ganz praktisch, dass man nicht irgendwie alles auf persisch einstellt und der nächste, der auf die Seite kommt, sich dann dadurch hangeln muss.
Okay, dann gehe ich jetzt mal hier auf Deutsch. Ich habe ja einen Account. Unendlichkeit. Darunter steht Aufhebung von Endlichkeit.
Genau, das ist die Description, also die Beschreibung dieses Items. Das ist gerade bei Unendlichkeit oder Q1 ist zum Beispiel das Universum. Ist das manchmal ein bisschen schwierig zu machen, irgendwie dafür eine fluffige Beschreibung zu finden? Aber naja, also wenn es dann halt irgendwie um Schauspieler geht, die den gleichen Namen haben, dann kann man halt sagen, der Schauspieler, der das und das gemacht hat, das Universum, Gesamtheit aller Planeten, Sterne, Galaxien, des intergalaktischen Raums und aller Materie und Energie.
Das heißt, jedes Item, jeder Wissensgegenstand, der in Wikidata abgelegt ist, hat einen Titel, aber nicht nur einen Titel, sondern hat in jeder denkbaren Sprache einen Titel. Genau, das heißt, Wikidata ist auch anders, als man das jetzt von Wikipedia kennt. Hat es jetzt nicht so ein D-E-E-N nochmal in der Domain davor, sondern es gibt nur das eine Wikidata, es gibt nur www.wikidata.org und da sind alle Sprachen berücksichtigt, das ist quasi eine Eigenschaft des Systems, dass jedes Ding in sich mehrsprachig sein kann.
Ja, und auch nicht nur mehrsprachig, also das ist sehr, sehr wichtig, dass ich halt Universum und Universe habe und das zeigt alles auf Q1, sondern ich kann halt in der Wikidata durchaus 10 Items haben, die alle als Titel Universum haben.
Und nicht Universum-Klammer auf deutsche Technik-Firma oder sowas. Das Lämmer, wenn man die Wikipediasprache übertrifft, ist einfach die Zahl. Also Q1 ist immer Q1, das Universum ist immer genau dieses eine Universum. Und es mag andere Dinge geben, die auch Universum heißen, aber die haben halt eine andere Zahl. Und deswegen ist auch die URL entsprechend anders. Und dieser Wissensgegenstand, dieses Item hat also jetzt immer einen Titelfeld. Und es hat immer eine Description heißt das dann da drunter sozusagen.
Genau, eine Beschreibung.
Das ist so quasi so ein Satz, mit dem man das knapp beschreibt.
Genau, es geht um das und nicht um das. Das sollte ausgefüllt sein, das ist nicht immer so der Fall. Also speziell, wenn dann halt eine Seite in der deutschen Wikipedia nicht existiert, dann kann es durchaus sein, dass es keinen deutschen Titel gibt und keine deutsche Description. Aber das wird immer mehr nachgetragen.
Das heißt, dann kann ich auch hingehen und sage Edit und dann kann ich das einfach eintragen und dann bin ich schon wieder so voll im Wikipediamoment sozusagen.
Und darunter, also unter der Description sehen wir jetzt irgendwie auch bekannt als, das sind die Aliasse, also das Universum ist auch bekannt als Weltall oder Kosmos. Stimmt nicht ganz, aber ja, das wären halt so Aliasse, die dann auch im...
Was stimmt da nicht?
Ist Kosmos nicht irgendwie eine Untermenge von Universum?
Würde ich jetzt nicht so sehen. Gut, schon alles irgendwie.
So, und wenn ich oben gibt's ein Suchfeld und wenn ich da Kosmos eingebe, dann bekomme ich auch vorgeschlagen das Universum als Q1, also als Item.
Beziehungsweise jetzt, wenn wir mal von dieser Sendung ausgehen, 205, da haben wir dann halt die Unendlichkeit und das ist die Aufhebung von Unendlichkeit.
Von Endlichkeit.
Entschuldigung, die Aufhebung von Endlichkeit. Sehr schön formuliert. Bestimmt jemand sehr lange darüber nachgedacht. Auch bekannt als unendlich und auch bekannt als liegende Acht.
Piffig.
Und das hilft sozusagen, um in Wikidata selbst dann auch diese Items zu finden quasi. Genau. Und auch gleich alternative Benennungen.
Und dann fängt es an mit den Aussagen, die zu diesem Item gemacht werden können. Bei 205 kommt als erstes, Unendlichkeit ist eine Unterklasse von Abstraktion. Weil richtig schönes Item uns ausgesucht. Dann gibt es eine Comments-Kategorie. Also Comments ist dieses Repository von Medien, also hauptsächlich Bilder, ein bisschen Sound, ein bisschen Filme, ein paar PDFs. Und in dieser Comments-Kategorie Infinity finde ich dann alle möglichen Medien, also Bilder und so weiter, die irgendwas mit Unendlichkeit zu tun haben.
Also mit Kategorie ist an der Stelle wirklich diese Wikipedia-Kategorie gemeint, die so üblicherweise mit Kategorie-Doppelpunkt in der URL zu finden ist.
Ja, das könnte auch sicherlich noch weitergehen. Also es wird auch im Moment schwer daran geschraubt, vielleicht wenn ihr jetzt den Podcast hört, ist das auch schon alles Geschichte, aber ich kann ja nur den momentanen Stand wieder geben. Es wird schwer daran geschraubt, die Comments viel näher an Wikidata anzubinden, sodass dann das, was man so schön als Metadaten bezeichnet, auch in Wikidata reinzubringen, sodass dann eine Verknüpfung viel schichtiger sein kann. Aber da diskutiert die Comments-Community noch drüber, was sie da genau haben wollen und wie das alles genau funktionieren soll.
Also wenn jetzt zum Beispiel so ein Bild da drin ist und das hat eine Geokoordinate, dann wäre das etwas, was man auch in Wikidata ablegen könnte.
Ja, und Bilder sind zu irgendeinem Zeitpunkt entstanden.
Autor haben sie genommen, ja.
Genau, man könnte auch noch sagen, stellt das, das, das und das da und solche Sachen. Es passieren schon interessante Sachen. Also ich glaube, wenn man jetzt nach Martin Luther King sucht, dann kann man, da ist dann tatsächlich auch bei Wikidata verlinkt.
Schauen wir mal kurz nach, das ist Q8027. Das wird auf jeden Fall Bestand haben, kann man sagen. Also ich finde es mal schön, dass es mal stabile URLs gibt, weil das ist ja auch so ein Elend bei Wikidata.
Da haben wir auf jeden Fall auch zwei Bilder. Und ich kann sagen, dass ich mich da auch geirrt habe, aber es gibt bei einigen, auch dann von Comments verlinkt, ein Tonbeispiel von dem Menschen, wie er etwas spricht.
Ja, finde ich jetzt gerade nicht. Aber hier gibt es auf jeden Fall schon mal sehr viel weitreichendere Informationen als zum Beispiel zur Unendlichkeit. Das hält sich ja noch relativ kurz.
Genau, da gibt es Sachen, die halt für Bibliothekare sehr, sehr interessant sind. Für mich, der dem ein bisschen das Fachwissen in Bibliothekswissenschaften fehlt, kann ich da nicht so viel zu sagen. Aber es gibt sowas wie eine GND-Nummer, was halt auch so eine Einordnung für Dinge ist. Und ähnlich ist das halt mit dieser FIAF, LCCN, Library of Congress, Common Number heißt das, glaube ich.
Also so ein Objekt, ein Wissens-Item in irgendeiner Form bibliothekarisch eingeordnet ist und dementsprechend eine eindeutige Nummer bekommen hat, kann man auch diese Informationen hier ablegen.
Genau, und es gibt halt verschiedene Filme, wo Martin Luther King in irgendeiner Art und Weise auftaucht. Das heißt, er hat auch eine IMDB-Identifikationsnummer. Es gibt Tonaufnahmen von ihm. Das heißt, in der Tonmusikdatenbank MusicBrainz hat er dann auch eine ID. Es gibt natürlich eine Comments-Kategorie. Und es gibt ja dann darunter bei allen menschlichen Lebewesen gibt es auch ein Geschlecht, was auch irgendwie gleich so einer der ersten Streitpunkte bei Wikidata war. Denn nicht in allen Sprachen ist das so eindeutig übersetzbar. Erstmal diese Kategorie Geschlecht. Also selbst beim Englischen gibt es irgendwie zwei Übersetzungen mit Sex und Gender. Und beim Französischen gibt es halt zum Beispiel eine Art, wie du über das Geschlecht von Menschen und über das Geschlecht von Tieren redest. Das müsstest du dann halt noch aufsplitten und so weiter. Also man kommt da an große Probleme. Ich will jetzt gar nicht erst anfangen mit den verschiedenen Statements, die unter Geschlecht abgelegt sind bei Chelsea Manning. Da gibt es nämlich drei oder vier. Du kriegst natürlich, weil du Deutsch eingestellt hast, kriegst du noch den Geburtsnamen angezeigt, der in der deutschen Wikipedia leider benutzt wird.
Das gibt es jetzt hier, Geschlecht gibt es dann. Vielleicht nochmal kurz diese Aussagen nochmal ein bisschen aufklären, was jetzt hier eigentlich steht. Jetzt wird es nämlich hier ganz schön divers. Also vorher hatten wir bei Martin Luther King so Geschlecht männlich fertig.
Gab es auch eine Quelle zu oder zwei?
Okay, also jetzt sind wir hier bei Bradley Manning, also wenn ich jetzt auf Englisch umschalte, dann ist es Chelsea Manning oder was? Richtig. Wo ist es da? Zack, Englisch. Bleiben wir doch mal kurz vielleicht in der Englischen tatsächlich. Also hier heißt dann derselbe Artikel Chelsea Manning, weil da einfach eine andere Konvention ist. Also Leute werden so genannt, wie sie sich jetzt selbst nennen.
Also es gab ein großes hin und her, großen politischen Streit, wie der Artikel in der Englischsprache in Wikipedia heißt. Der hat zeitweilig auch mal den Namen gewechselt, aber jetzt ist der Konsens, dass der Artikel Chelsea Manning heißt.
Okay, aber dieser ganze Blog, über den wir jetzt gesprochen haben, nachdem wir von Titelbeschreibungen und den Aliasen weggekommen sind, heißt im Englischen Statements, im Deutschen Aussagen anders. Aber das ist jetzt sozusagen so eine grundlegende Eigenschaft von Wikidata, Dinge zu beschreiben. Also man sagt, man schafft eine Aussage.
Genau, und in dieser Aussage gibt es sogenannte Claims, also Behauptungen. Das ist jetzt hier in dem Fall bei Chelsea Manning sogar relativ interessant, weil hier widersprüchliche Aussagen nebeneinander stehen. Also widersprüchliche Claims können nebeneinander stehen, so es denn idealerweise dafür eine Quelle gibt.
Okay, das heißt, die Aussage erst mal an sich bezieht sich jetzt erst mal auf eine bestimmte Eigenschaft, also diese Property heißt das. Und das Property im Englischen ist jetzt Sex, im Deutschen mit Geschlecht übersetzt. Und jetzt gibt es zu diesem Property drei Claims.
Sehe ich das richtig?
Also es gibt drei Claims. Genau, und der Claim eins ist, es handelt sich hierbei um einen Mann. Dafür gibt es fünf Quellen. Die schwedische Wikipedia.
Das soll auch, da gibt es gerade in der Community Diskussionen, dass diese ganzen Quellenangabe, so und so sprachige Wikipedia, dann verschwinden sollen auch durch eine Bot-Initiative, weil das auch relativ selbstreferenziell und quatschig ist.
Ja, okay, aber steht jetzt auf jeden Fall mal drin, dann gibt es hier noch ein Virtual International Authority File.
Was irgendwann mal festgestellt hat, dass JC. Manning männlich ist.
Genau, wobei diese Quellen jetzt heißen, ist das auch nochmal so eine Property hier oder was? Ja, genau, also die Property ist imported from, bla, Wikipedia, imported from Virtual International Authority File, also dieses VIAF, was ich glaube ich schon mal anklang, dann stated in United States versus Bradley Manning. Also das bezieht sich jetzt wahrscheinlich auf diesen Gerichtsakten, um diesen Prozess sozusagen. Also da wurde das gesagt oder wurde es niedergeschrieben. Also sprich, man hat eine Property. Dazu gibt es verschiedene Behauptungen, wie denn dieses Property nun sei. Und wir befinden uns jetzt hier immer noch sozusagen in Behauptung Nummer eins, dass es sich bei Chelsea Manning um einen Mann handelt oder das Geschlecht männlich ist, um mal korrekt zu sein. Und dafür werden fünf Quellen gesagt. Und es sind halt drei importierte Quellen und zwei, wie soll man das sagen, Zitate, oder? Dass es da was gibt, wo das so steht. Das heißt, man belegt quasi seine Aussage, indem man explizit auf bestimmte, ja, was eigentlich verweist. Auch letztlich wieder auf Wikipedia-Artikel an der Stelle.
Ja, das sind aber Items in Wikidata dann auch selber.
Genau, also andere Items, die letztlich dann auch wiederum Wikipedia-Artikel sind.
Genau, der Prozess United States versus Bradley Manning hat auch ein Wikidata-Item.
Genau, und das ist dann irgendwie Q7893231. Und dahinter steht natürlich dann ein oder mehrere Wikipedia-Artikel in den jeweiligen Sprachvarianten. So, das war jetzt Claim Nummer eins. Und jetzt gibt es noch einen zweiten Claim, dass es sich nämlich dabei um ein Transgender Female handelt.
Wenn du das jetzt umschaltest auf Deutsch, da gab es auch bis vor kurzem gar keine deutsche Entsprechung für das Property Transgender Female.
Schauen wir mal, wie sich das jetzt hier Transfrau steht da. Aber so oder so null Quellen, das heißt, das hat irgendjemand reingeschrieben, ohne es jetzt zu belegen.
Ist das stadthaft? Das ist stadthaft, ja. Irgendwann fängt jeder Aussage so an, mit null Quellen.
Genau, eine Birne ist eine Frucht.
Wir würden uns das wünschen, wenn es zu allem eine Quelle gibt. Und das wird auch in Zukunft ein bisschen mehr forciert werden, glaube ich, von der Community, dass die Verlässlichkeit in die Aussagen dann halt steigt, indem man mehr Quellen hinzufügt. Aber mehr Quellen an sich heißt auch nichts, das ist jetzt richtiger, weil es mehr Quellen dafür gibt. Das ist eine ganz wichtige philosophische Sache von Wikidata. Wir bilden da keine Wahrheiten ab, sondern wir bilden Behauptungen ab. Und diese Behauptungen haben idealerweise eine Quelle, eine Referenz.
Das ist eigentlich mal ein schönes Statement zu dem Grundansatz von Wikipedia, weil es hat sich ja so ein bisschen eingebürgert. Nach dem Motto, der Witz, steht in der Wikipedia, ist also wahr. Hier nimmt man das im Prinzip gleich auf und sagt, steht in Wikidata, ist also eine Behauptung.
Ist erstmal so eine Behauptung. Also ein anderes, schönes, kontroverses Beispiel, was wir am Anfang auch immer gerne in Präsentationen benutzt werden. In der hebräischen und arabischen Wikipedia ist die Einwohnerzahl von Israel unterschiedlich angegeben, weil sie unterschiedliche Berechnungsgrundlagen benutzen. Jetzt könnte man natürlich sagen, kein Problem, wir lösen einfach den Nahost-Konflikt und dann werden die sich schon auf einen Standard einigen. Oder man könnte sagen, nein, die Welt ist einfach ein bisschen komplexer und wir werden damit leben müssen, dass unterschiedliche Wahrheiten einfach nebeneinander existieren und auch beide belegbar sind auf eine Art. Das heißt, beide sind Vegetator abgebildet.
Und wenn ich jetzt so eine Infobox habe, die ihre Einwohnerzahl automatisch herbeiholt und da stehen dann zwei, dann steht da eine Liste von Einwohnerzahlen.
Das wäre dann eine Aufgabe, eine Challenge an die Programmierer von dieser Infobox in Wikipedia. Oder ich kann es mir einfach vorstellen, dass dann die entsprechenden, also arabische, bräische, Wikipedia, die werden einfach ein Select machen auf die Quelle, der sie vertrauen und die sich da in der Diskussion als akzeptabel rausgestellt wird.
Das heißt, unterscheiden tun sich die beiden Aussagen eigentlich nur dadurch, dass sie andere Quellen haben?
Genau, dass sie sogenannte Qualifiers haben. Also diese Aussagen werden dann nochmal qualifiziert, zum Beispiel durch Quellen. Aber auch, und deswegen war jetzt bei Chelsea Manning, da gibt es für die Aussage Chelsea Manning ist weiblich, gibt es einen Startzeitpunkt. Also wir haben mal eine Art von Zeit dann auch noch da reingebaut. Und da ist jetzt angegeben, dass diese Aussage ihren Startzeitpunkt am 22. August 2013 hat.
Ah, also ist weiblich, aber war nicht immer weiblich. Das ist quasi so das, was man da rauslesen kann.
Ja, das ist der Inhalt dieser Aussage. Ob da jetzt alle mit zufrieden wären.
Ja, da steht jetzt auch noch dabei, ist eine Instanz von Geschlechtsidentitätsstörung.
Auch das ist eine Aussage, die man halt mit Wikidata machen kann. Und wie man das jetzt inhaltlich einsortiert, kann man darüber diskutieren.
Man merkt, glaube ich, an der Stelle auch, dass es hier jetzt kein abgeschlossenes Projekt ist. Es ist nicht so, dass Wikidata jetzt schon festgelegt hätte, wie diese Welt zu beschreiben ist. Es handelt sich lediglich um ein technisches Gerüst, um sie zu beschreiben. Aber welche Aussagen hier letzten Endes die Wahrheit TM machen und auf welche Art und Weise sie das letztlich dann inhaltlich tun, das befindet sich noch im Fluss.
Absolut. Also da bin ich auch sehr, sehr froh, dass wir bei dieser ganzen Datenbankstruktur eigentlich immer die Flexibilität an erster Stelle gesetzt haben. Denn wir behandeln hier das Wissen der Menschheit. Das hat irgendwie was mit Gesellschaft und Diskurs zu tun. Das ist im ständigen Wandel begriffen, wie Menschen auf die Welt und ihr Wissen gucken. Da jetzt eine rigide Datenbankstruktur, das ist aber ein Mussfeld einzuführen. Das würde einfach der Sache nicht gerecht werden.
An der Stelle unterscheidet sich zum Beispiel auch von diesem Semantik-Wiki-Ansatz, was irgendwie mehr oder weniger sagt, ja, das ist ein X, also das kann jetzt nur A oder B sein.
Und um auch mal wegzukommen von dieser Idee, es würde die ganze Zeit nur um politische Einschätzungen der Realität gestritten werden. Einwohnerzhaft von Israel und Geschlecht von Chelsea Manning und so weiter. Es gibt einfach auch Sachen, da kannst du einfach wissenschaftlich nichts sagen. Also es gibt irgendwelche Könige, von denen man weiß, dass sie irgendwie im 5. Jahrhundert gelebt haben. Aber das ist auch wirklich das Einzige, was man über die sagen kann. Also man kann nicht den Geburtstag und vielleicht sogar nicht mal das Geburtsjahr angeben. Und das wäre einfach Quatsch, das dann vorzuschreiben, dass jeder Mensch einen definierten Geburtstag haben muss. Manchmal kann man einfach nur sagen, der ist geboren. Und dass dieses Ereignis hat sich irgendwann im 5. Jahrhundert abgespielt.
Es gibt ja ohnehin eine ganze Menge Umstrittenes. Also nicht nur jetzt so geschichtliche Bewertung und irgendwie ist jetzt irgendjemand böse oder nicht. Also was weiß ich, ist Homöopathie eine Medizin oder so? Wo dann auch wahrscheinlich sehr viele unterschiedliche Aussagen zusammenkommen über die Zeit. Aber die dann quasi die Chance haben, sich eben auch zu bewähren. Und dafür gibt es diese und jene Quellen. Und für die andere Aussage mag es auch irgendwelche geben, aber die sind sie jetzt zumindest mal genannt.
Ja, wobei ich da auch irgendwie sagen würde, die Aussage, Chelsea Mending ist männlich, mit fünf Quellen belegt, davon zwei aus Wikipedien, ist dadurch nicht die richtige. Also das ist da fünf Quellen und deswegen ist es die richtige Aussage.
Ja, nicht gesagt, dass die Mehrheit entscheidet, aber man kann sozusagen, das muss ja jetzt auch nicht unbedingt so bleiben. Also wahrscheinlich ist jetzt schon zwei Wochen nach diesem Podcast hat sich hier schon wieder eine ganz andere Realität abgebildet, als die, die wir jetzt hier beschrieben haben. Gut, also muss man mal zusammenfassen. Man hat Items. Ich finde den Begriff Wissensgegenstand, finde ich eigentlich sehr schön. Hat einen Titel, hat eine Beschreibung, hat Alias. Dann kommen Aussagen. Eine Aussage bezieht sich immer erstmal auf ein Property, auf eine Eigenschaft. Für diese Eigenschaft gibt es dann eine ein oder mehrere Behauptungen, Claims, die darüber gefällt werden. Der Claim besteht jetzt erstmal aus der Zuordnung eines Werts, eines anderen Items.
Ein Wert steht da erstmal drin. Dieser Wert kann verschiedene Datentypen haben. Der Datentyp, der als erstes drin war, war ein anderes Item. Also, bleiben wir hier, Geschlecht. Am Anfang gab es die beiden Werte männlich und weiblich. Diese beiden Werte sind auch selbst Items in Wikidata.
Damit haben sie dann auch gleich wieder alle Sprachen etc. und können auch selber noch mal beschrieben werden. Das heißt, häufig ist eine Aussage einfach nur, dem Property wird Item sowieso zugewiesen.
Genau, das ist eine Grundsache. Mittlerweile gibt es andere Datentypen auch. Es gibt den Datentyp Zeit. Den hatten wir jetzt kurz angesprochen bei Startzeitpunkt. Da ist sehr viel Gehirnschmalz reingeflossen. Denn um geschichtliche Sachen abzudecken, kommt man dann von Höchstchen auf Stöckchen, was die Geschichte der Kalendersysteme angeht. Im Moment kann man auf jeden Fall griech-äurianische und julianische Kalenderdaten eingeben, was halt auch relativ wichtig ist. Also so ein Ereignis wie die Revolution in Russland ist halt in allen geschichtlichen Werken immer mindestens mit beiden Daten angegeben. Es gibt auch Spezialitäten, die dann betrachtet wurden, wo eine normale Datenbank sagt, hier, das ist eine Falschaussage oder so, da sind wir da ein bisschen weitergegangen, wirklich extrem wurde da geforscht und so. Es gab, ich mich richtig erinnere, in Finnland oder in Schweden, aber ich glaube, in Finnland gab es in einem Jahr auch mal einen 31. Februar, der eingeführt wurde bei der Umstellung von hirianisch auf grigorianischen Kalender. Und diesen 31. Februar für dieses Jahr kannst du auch tatsächlich als Datum eingeben.
Und vieles denke ich, man ist sicher auch überhaupt gar nicht mit so einem spezifischen Datum so genau beschreiben. Und es ist trotzdem eine zeitliche Einordnung. Also ich weiß nicht, so was wie Steinzeit oder so was.
Genau, Erdzeitalter oder so was, da sagst du dann einfach, das hätte ich gerne vor fünf, so vier Millionen Jahren.
Irgendwann dann muss es mal, also Ötzi ist irgendwie gestorben.
Und was ich eben schon sagte halt, du hast einen König, du weißt, dass der im fünften Jahrhundert aktiv war, aber du hast weder...
Quellen?
Weder Geburts- noch Sterbedatum ist halt irgendwie belegt, aber du kannst dann sagen, ja, irgendwie geboren und gestorben.
Muss nach sowieso gewesen sein und vor X. Okay, also nochmal, Property, dem wird was zugewiesen, ein Wert. Ach so, du warst gerade dabei, diese Values, also man kann natürlich auch ganz normale Zahlen eingeben, wenn es jetzt kein Datum ist, oder?
Sollte man denken, dass wir das als erstes gemacht haben, ist gerade auch in der Mache, wird auch relativ schnell dabei sein. Bei ganz normalen Zahlen hast du noch viel mehr Probleme als bei Zeiteinheiten. Denn was wir gerne haben wollten, das war ein Ziel von Wikidata von Anfang an, dass wir das Prinzip der Maßeinheiten dann auch drin haben. Also dass in der englischen Wikipedia dann zum Beispiel Meilen und Kilometer gleichberechtigt angezeigt wird, Fahrenheit und Celsius gleichberechtigt angezeigt wird, während in der deutschsprachigen Wikipedia wirklich nur Kilometer und Celsius gemacht wird. Aber du könntest auch ein Ding haben, dass du dann die entsprechenden anderen Maßeinheiten dir noch als Query reinholst. Dann gibt es verschiedene Arten von wissenschaftlichen Notationen für ganz normale Zahlen, die z.B. in Astronomie sehr wichtig werden. Bei großen Zahlen gibt es verschiedene Möglichkeiten, das wissenschaftlich zu notieren. Wir kennen diese Taschenrechner-Notation, die dann auf jeden Fall auch benutzt werden muss. Plus, Minus, Brüche in verschiedenen Arten und Formen. Ganz normale Zahlen sind nur oberflächlich betrachtet.
Wenn es so etwas wie die Einwohnerzahl niederschreibert, ist das dann die Einheit?
Da ist dann halt keine Einheit, das ist einfach nur eine Ganzzahl. Das gibt es auch, aber es geht noch sehr viel weiter. Dann gibt es natürlich den Datentyp String, wo wir ein bisschen Angst hatten, wenn wir den einführen, dann drehen die in der Community durch und benutzen alles, was noch nicht da ist und schreiben da einfach String rein. Dann haben wir überhaupt keine semantische Verknüpfung mehr, ist aber so nicht passiert.
Was würde man jetzt typischerweise in einem einfachen String ablegen und nicht in einem Item?
Puh, weiß ich nicht. Gibt es auch Anwendungsfälle?
Vielleicht.
Es gibt auch Fälle, wo der String sinnvoll eingesetzt wird. Ich müsste nachschauen.
Das ist schon eher die Ausnahme?
Das ist die Ausnahme. Es ist auch so gewünscht, dass es die Ausnahme ist. Eigentlich soll alles schön qualifiziert, strukturiert und semantisch zugewiesen sein.
Okay, ich rolle nochmal zurück. Das scheint mir sehr wichtig zu sein, das wirklich zu verstehen. Das Statement, das Property, dem wird ein Wert zugewiesen. Dieser Wert kann dann noch, wie hast du das genannt? Qualifier enthalten. Ich habe zwar hier einen Wert zugewiesen, aber für diese Wertezuweisung gelten bestimmte Bedingungen. Kann man das so sagen?
Es gibt so Rahmendaten. Genau, Deutschland zum Beispiel, so ist das Item.
Da weißt du bestimmt die Zahl auswendig.
Leider nicht alle Zahlen.
Das ist so die Beschäftigung, bei wem das demnächst so irgendwie. Ich kann alle Item-Nummern von Wikidata auswendig.
183, Q183.
Da merkt man, dass Deutschland eine Rolle gespielt hat.
Also alle souveränen Staaten sind ziemlich vorne. Da haben wir irgendwie einfach mal einen Schwupps reingeholt. Genau.
Was finden wir hier?
Da finden wir zum Beispiel eine Aussage. Also erste Aussage ist, Amtssprache ist Deutsch. Dafür gibt es auch eine Quelle. Nachgewiesen im Verwaltungsverfahrensgesetz. Und das Zitat ist, die Amtssprache ist Deutsch. Das wird wahrscheinlich ein String sein.
Ah, weil das steht nun mal genau nur in Deutsch da. Und das braucht nur... Ah, verstehe. Und dann gibt es schon eine zweite Aussage, nämlich Währung.
Währung und da stehen zwei Sachen genau nebeneinander. Nämlich einmal, die Währung von Deutschland ist der Euro. Und die andere Aussage ist, die Währung von Deutschland ist die Deutsche Mark. Und diese beiden Claims sind halt entsprechend qualifiziert.
Und beim Euro gibt es einen Startzeitpunkt, nämlich den 1. Januar 2002. Und beim Deutschen Mark gibt es auch einen Startzeitpunkt, 21. Juni 48, aber eben auch einen Endzeitpunkt. Nämlich der 31. Dezember.
Und wenn du jetzt weiter runter scrollst, dann siehst du die ganzen Staatsoberhäupter.
Deutschland ist eine Instanz von souveräner Staat.
Ja, ist so eine Aussage, der würde ich sogar zustimmen.
Wenn ich da jetzt eine Instanz von Überwachungsstaat reinschreibe, dann kriege ich gleich eins auf den Deckel.
Hoffentlich, ja. Ja, wir haben jetzt hier gemeinsame Grenzen, aber wenn du da noch mal weiter runtergehst...
Da steht ja eine Menge. Kontinent ist Europa.
Ja, ganze Wappen, Ländercode.
Oh ja, das ist ja auch sehr schön, dass die ganzen Domains da wahrscheinlich auch drin sind.
Ja, ist Teil von Mitteleuropa, ist Teil von Europäischer Union. Es gibt ganzen Untereinheiten, das sind die Bundesländer und so weiter.
Telefonvorwahl, Schutzpatronen.
Genau, der deutsche St. Michael ist der Schutzpatron. Man lernt dann sogar noch was. Wir haben hier auch noch geografische Koordinate unten.
Da gibt es aber keine Quelle für.
Da gibt es keine Quelle, aber da sieht man jetzt hier, das ist 51 Grad Nord, 10 Grad Ost. Und da gibt es natürlich auch ganz ganz viele Arten, das einzugeben. Also für Geolokation, das ist natürlich auch noch ein Datentyp, den ich eben gerade vergessen habe.
Ja, vor allem hier fehlt mir ja so ein bisschen die Ausdehnung. Genau, aber die Grenze als solche, also jetzt der konkrete, geografische Verlauf der Grenze als solcher, ist hier so nicht drin.
Ist erstmal nicht so drin, ja.
Also man kann sich da jetzt keinen Atlas draus bauen.
Es ist was drin ist, mit wem es sich die Grenze teilt. Und ich hoffe ja wirklich, dass da sich noch irgendwelche Geo-Nerds mal austoben und Sachen schaffen, von denen ich jetzt im Moment noch gar keine Vorstellung habe. Aber das ist nichts, was die Software irgendwie so vorgibt, sondern das wird dann...
Aber man könnte jetzt zumindest schon mal so ein kleines Skript schreiben, was versucht, zwischen zwei Ländern den kürzesten Weg über die Grenzen sozusagen zu finden, weil die Information ist ja da.
Und das könnte du jetzt auch dann die Ausgabe dann in Echtzeit lokalisiert in allen Sprachen dann machen. Also du könntest da irgendwie dann in Arabisch Deutschland eingeben und du könntest sagen, die Ausgabe hätte ich aber auf Chinesisch gerne und dann alles würde hoffentlich funktionieren.
Also wenn ich jetzt hier diese geografische Koordinate mal öffne, also wenn ich jetzt mal wirklich sage, ich will das jetzt mal ändern und klick das an, dann passiert ja hier richtig was, dann geht hier erstmal ein großes Feld auf, was mir verschiedene Möglichkeiten gibt, das einzugeben.
Genau.
Da weiß ich jetzt nicht, was da jetzt noch greift, aber das ist ja sozusagen so ein Kerndatentyp, das heißt, er weiß, jetzt kommt eine Koordinate. Das muss ja aber auch irgendwo definiert sein.
Das ist auch sehr ehrlich irgendwo definiert.
In diesem Property dann sozusagen.
Ja, da gibt es wahrscheinlich auch noch eine Unterseite.
Aber man könnte jetzt hier auch noch eine Genauigkeit der Koordinate angeben.
Genau, und dann halt auch noch die Abweichung in Grad und so weiter.
Das heißt, ich kann hier sozusagen schon mal so grob sagen, wie ist es. Und das war jetzt, glaube ich, eingestellt mit to a degree.
Wenn du das jetzt nicht als Wikidata-Vandale, dann kannst du einfach auf abbrechen.
Deswegen wird es auch nur so angezeigt. Also es wird nur gesagt 51 Grad Nord, 10 Grad Ost. Da so in etwa plus minus ein Grad.
Genau, und für andere Sachen.
Bei Russland ist es dann wahrscheinlich eher plus minus 10 Grad. Verstehe.
Genau, und direkt darunter ist dann das Staatsoberhaupt. Und da haben wir auch dann alle Staatsoberhäupte der Bundesrepublik Deutschland seit 1948 mit jeweils Startzeitpunkt und Endzeitpunkt angegeben. Zum Teil mit Quellen, zum Teil mit Bestimmungsmethoden. Genau, die sind halt alle durch die Bundesversammlung gewählt worden in einem bestimmten Jahr. Und über diese Wahl der Bundesversammlung in diesem bestimmten Jahr, das sind halt auch wieder Wissensgegenstände, die entsprechend Qualifizierung haben können. Wie viele Mitglieder gab es damals in der Bundesversammlung?
Ach so, das heißt, wenn ich jetzt hier Theodor Heuss Bestimmungsmethode Wahl des deutschen Bundespräsidenten 1949 anklicke, dann komme ich jetzt zu dem Item Q314561, Wahl des deutschen Bundespräsidenten. Und da steht zwar jetzt diese Information, die du meintest, nicht drin, aber da könnte ich sie halt reinschreiben.
Genau, und da ist der Vorgänger, nämlich die Reichspräsidentenwahl 1932. Also da gab es kurze Pause zwischen. Und Nachfolger ist auch irgendwie.
Also auch so geschichtliche Kontinuität lässt sich hier auch abbilden. Übergänge von Rechtssystemen.
Man könnte einen Zeitstrahl auch wirklich machen und das dann entsprechend visualisieren. Der Punkt, den ich eigentlich damit machen wollte, ist, das sind alles gleichberechtigte Claims. Also Theodor Heuss ist erstmal genauso Bundespräsident wie Gauck. Nur durch die Qualifiers wird dann mit End- und Startzeitpunkt dann noch zusätzliche Aussagen gemacht.
Sodass, wenn man jetzt sagt, ok, dann bringe ich das jetzt mal in Relation zu einem Ja und dann weiß ich, ob er da der aktuelle Präsident war oder nicht. Ja, worauf sollten wir noch? Das ist ja ein relativ unendliches Ding hier. Es kommen natürlich noch die ganzen Bundeskanzler gleich hinterher. Auch sehr schön, wo man so alles so Mitglied ist. Also man ist nicht nur ein Teil der Europäischen Union, man ist auch noch ein Mitglied der Europäischen Union. Aber da können wir schön sehen, wo man jetzt sozusagen welchem internationalen Pakt beigetreten ist als Land.
Und auch wann?
Also Europäische Union, NATO, OECD, Europarat, Gruppe der Acht, Europäische Weltraumorganisationen, Welthandelsorganisationen und noch diverse andere Sachen.
Und auch da wieder dann bei Hauptstadt zwei sich widersprechende Claims, nämlich Bonn und Berlin. Und das eine hat dann Endzeitpunkt.
Und Feiertage, da gibt es nur einer.
Das ist die Übersetzung von, ich glaube, National Holiday oder sowas, bei den meisten Tagen dann irgendwie Unabhängigkeitstag oder sowas ist. Und da ist einfach der Feiertag, die Übersetzung taugt meiner Meinung nach nichts, weil es gibt natürlich mehr Feiertage als am Tag der Deutschen Einheit. Aber es gibt natürlich nur einen Nationalfeiertag.
Das heißt, man müsste jetzt mal da drauf gehen. Das bringt uns vielleicht an der Stelle mal auf die Properties selber, weil wir haben ja jetzt die ganze Zeit nur darüber geredet, was sind Items, was sind sozusagen diese Wissensgegenstände. Und diese Properties, die sind ja selbst keine, sondern die sind was anderes. Das heißt, wenn wir jetzt mal auf diese Feiertage selber hier draufklicken, dann ändert sich auch oben die URL und auf einmal steht da nicht Q irgendwas, sondern...
Property-Doppelopp-P832.
Das heißt, es ist in einem anderen Namespace innerhalb von diesem Media-Wiki. Das heißt, die Items sind in einem eigenen Namespace. Und bei Wikidata ist es so der Default-Namespace.
Genau, kann man einstellen, wie man möchte, wenn man das installiert. Aber bei Wikidata ist halt der Beschluss gewesen, hier, worum es eigentlich geht, sind die Items. Und deswegen wird das der Default-Namespace. Bei der Wikipedia ist darum, worum es geht, sind die Artikel.
Aber es gibt auch noch die normalen Artikel, weil es ist ja am Ende, ist ja auch Wikidata Org immer noch ein Wiki.
Ja, aber es ist kein Wiki zur Erstellung einer Enzyklopädie. Das heißt, es gibt erstmal viel, viel weniger Artikel, die da drin sind. Und das meiste ist auch irgendwie in einer Form organisatorisch. Also es gibt Wikidata, Doppelpunkt, Forum. Da tauschen sich die Leute an dem Projekt aus. Genau, es gibt eine Seite für News, wo dann gesagt wird, wir haben die und die neue Softwareversion und jetzt ist das und das. Das neue Property ist jetzt entstanden und so weiter. Es gibt Status-Update, wo jede Woche ein kleiner Newsletter verschickt wird und so weiter.
Und was ich auch gerade sehe, das ist ja sozusagen in den normalen Wikipedien so nicht drin, dass man ja implizit ja immer diese Mehrsprachigkeit hat. Das heißt, ich kann jetzt hier auch die Hilfe gleich mehrsprachig anlegen. Also das ist sozusagen etwas, was MediaWiki jetzt selber kann und was nur hier das erste Mal wirklich benutzt wird.
Die linken dann auf unterschiedliche Seiten.
Gut, sehr viel mehr gibt es jetzt nicht zu sagen. Das heißt, wenn man so ein Property angelegt hat, dann kann man das auch gleich benutzen. Und das steht jetzt auch erstmal abgesehen davon, dass es in so einem anderen Namespace steht genauso vor meinem Auge. Das heißt, es hat wieder einen Titel, es hat eine Beschreibung, es hat eine Alias. Aber hier gibt es halt keine Aussagen darüber.
An der Stelle müssen wir ein bisschen trennen zwischen der Software, die unter Wikidata läuft, und der Community. Also wenn ich dann einfach so ein Property anlege, ist bei Wikidata der Community nicht so einfach möglich. Das ist auch sinnvoll. Also nicht, dass es da Doppelungen gibt. Das heißt, jedes Property, was da ist, steht am Ende eines Community-Prozesses, wo diskutiert wird, brauchen wir das, gibt es nicht ein anderes Property, das diese Aufgabe schon erfüllt, oder lässt sich das wirklich interkulturell, intersprachlich und so wirklich alles so festlegen, ist das ein Property, was die wissenschaftliche Community benutzt, und so weiter und so weiter.
Das heißt, Wikidata Org ist so eingestellt, ich kann zwar jederzeit, wie das hier so schön heißt, ein neues Datenobjekt erstellen.
Also ein Item.
Ja, ein Item kann ich jederzeit erstellen, aber ich kann mir nicht mal ein neues Property einfallen lassen, weil man möchte gerne nur die Properties wirklich eintragen, wo man sich vorher in so einem Community-Prozess darüber einig geworden ist, dass man das auch wirklich haben will. Weil sonst wäre es der totale Wildwuchs und am Ende wüsste keiner mehr so richtig, was jetzt eigentlich gilt.
Denk ich auch, find ich auch auf eine gewisse Art und Weise sehr, sehr sinnvoll. Also dass halt neue Items jederzeit angelegt werden können, ohne Diskussion. Aber bei Properties, dass dann zumindest, ja, mal diskutiert wird. Wobei ich halt auch finde, dass die Wikidata-Community, vielleicht ändert sich das noch, vielleicht ist sie einfach noch sehr jung und enthusiastisch, aber der Ton, der da herrscht, ist ein sehr, sehr freundlicher.
Gut. Es gibt noch mehr als nur Aussagen.
Gibt es. Und das ist das, womit Wikidata sozusagen gestartet hat und womit wir die Herzen und Hirne der Wikipedia-Community, glaube ich, auch erobert haben. Das ist nämlich die Interlanguage Links, Wikipedia-Seiten, die mit diesem Objekt verlinkt sind. Denn ganz am Anfang unseres Gesprächs habe ich immer gesagt, das ist sehr erstaunlich, dass die Community solche Fleißarbeiten übernommen hat, wie in jeder Wikipedia-Seite nachtragen, wie dieser Artikel in einer anderen Sprache heißt. Und das bei über 200 Projekten. Bei vielen kleinen Wikis war das zum Teil das Einzige, was da passiert ist. Also es gab nicht genügend Artikelschreiber, aber es gab immer irgendwelche Bots, die dann herumgelaufen sind und gesagt haben, hier dieser Artikel heißt aber jetzt auf der und der Sprache so und so. Und wenn man dann auf letzte Änderungen geklickt hat, Recent Changes, dann hat man häufiger eigentlich nur gesehen, hier Verlinkung ins Arabische wurde geändert zu so und so. Und damit war eigentlich die ganze Seite voll mit solchen Mini-Änderungen, die dann immer noch an den Artikel angefügt worden sind, die nur damit zu tun hatten, wie heißt dieses Objekt eigentlich in anderen Sprachen. Da hat es sich einfach angeboten, dafür ein Repository, einen Datenfundus zu machen, wo das dann alles draus gespeist wird. Und das ist das erste Feature, das bei Wikidata an den Start gegangen ist. Und das ist im Oktober 2012, da ist Wikidata gestartet. Und nach ein bisschen Testen auf anderen Wikipedien ist das dann halt scharf geschaltet worden auf der englischen Wikipedia. Und sofort haben sich irgendwelche Bots daran gemacht, die Sprachverknüpfungen bei Wikidata einzutragen. Und im Anschluss dann aus dem Wikitext von den Wikipedien zu löschen. Und seitdem gucken wir eigentlich auch alle nicht mehr zurück auf die Zeit, wie es vorher war. Es hat sich einfach als so dermaßen praktisch herausgestellt, einen gemeinsamen Datenfundes für diese Verlinkung in die anderen Sprachen zu haben. Da möchte eigentlich niemand mehr zurück. Wenn man jetzt beim normalen Wikipedia-Artikel an die Seitenleiste guckt und dann sieht man in anderen Sprachen ganz unten einen Bleistift, wo man das dann noch ändern kann. Und wenn man da draufklickt, wird man auch direkt zu Wikidata weitergeleitet und kann dann halt noch eine weitere Sprachversion eintragen.
Das heißt, diese Querverweise sind jetzt keine Änderungen mehr des Artikels selber? Das heißt, auch für einen einzelnen Artikel ist das ja auch relevant. Also eine Änderung dürfte jetzt in den meisten Fällen wirklich eine inhaltliche Änderung sein an dem eigentlichen Artikel und nicht so sehr so eine Meta-Änderung, die eigentlich mit dem Inhalt so gar nichts zu tun hat. Das heißt, das ist jetzt hier so eine... Ich meine, hätte man das jetzt nicht auch einfach als Aussage formulieren können, hat damit so nichts zu tun. Also es ist jetzt quasi noch mal so ein extra...
Ist noch mal so ein extra Ding. So ein extra Hack. Kann natürlich auch ausgeschaltet werden. Es gibt ja auch Leute, die sich diese Software, die darunter liegt, Wikibase, installieren und jetzt vielleicht nicht unbedingt ein Projekt in 200 Sprachen dahinter haben. Das heißt also, dieses ganze mehrsprachige Seitending interessiert den nicht so richtig. Und da kann man dann einfach sagen, hier, wollen wir nicht haben, schalten wir aus.
Dazu mal, wenn man jetzt heute so eine Wikipedia baut, wenn ich das jetzt richtig verstanden habe, mit dem aktuellen Media-Wiki kann ich ja diese Mehrsprachigkeit auch innerhalb eines einzelnen Wikis herstellen, oder?
Es gibt da unheimlich viele Sachen, die halt dann auch wieder dem geschuldet sind, dass die Welt halt dann doch komplexer ist, als man es denkt. Also es gibt zum Beispiel bei der serbischen Wikipedia, da gibt es einfach zwei Arten, serbisch zu schreiben, nämlich mit kyrillischen Zeichen und mit latanischen Zeichen. Beide werden benutzt, das wird sich auch nicht ändern. Das heißt, da hast du auch bei der serbischsprachigen Wikipedia jederzeit die Möglichkeit, umzuswitchen, weil es eine definierte Konvertierung zwischen beiden Schreibweisen gibt. Also die Media-Wikisoftware bleibt da natürlich auch nicht stehen und passt sich dann halt in Gegebenheiten an.
Das heißt, das war so ein bisschen auch so der Hack, mit dem man jetzt Wikidata dem restlichen Projekt verkauft hat. Ich kann mir jetzt auch vorstellen, so viel Streit es gemeinhin ja gibt, dass es hier auch so ein paar ewiggestrige gibt, die vielleicht der Meinung sind, wir hätten das manuelle Editieren niemals verlassen dürfen.
Ja, ist erstaunlich für ein Projekt, das eigentlich so sehr vom Internet lebt, dass dann halt trotzdem so Traditionalisten dann auftauchen und sagen, ja, wir sind doch wie Diderot und wir schreiben im Kerzenlicht unsere Enzyklopädie und so weiter, weil das gibt es. Und die tragen ja auch nicht nur Quatsch bei zu dem Wikipedia-Projekt, aber mich freut es eigentlich sehr, dass die Grund-, also im Grundsatz stehen alle eigentlich diesem Wikidata-Projekt positiv gegenüber. Da gibt es dann halt irgendwie Radikale, die sagen irgendwie, hey, und demnächst werden ganze Artikel aus Wikidata automatisch generiert. Man muss dann nur hier und da einen Hilfsverb einfügen und am Schluss einen Punkt setzen, und dann hat man einen fertigen Artikel. Keine Ahnung, ob das irgendwie gangbar wird irgendwann. Es gibt andere, die sagen, ne, also eigentlich außer den Interlanguage-Links interessiert uns nichts. Aber es gibt auch zum Beispiel, es gibt auch zum Beispiel Leute, die sagen, ja, man kann das auch beides verbinden. Also ich kann schon, ich muss nicht unbedingt alles automatisch von irgendwelchen Robotern in meine Wikipedia rein lutschen lassen, aber ich kann Wikidata durchaus benutzen, um die Korrektheit von etwas festzustellen. Und da gibt es in der englischen Wikipedia zum Beispiel Leute, die Vorlagen schreiben, die dann versteckt nur für Admins anzeigbar sagen, hier ist eine Diskrepanz zwischen dem, was im Artikel steht und dem, was bei Wikidata steht und das wird dann auf eine nicht unbedingt für Benutzer sichtbare Unterkategorie geschoben, die man dann mal durchgucken kann, ob das dann okay ist. Denn es kann ja durchaus Gründe geben, nicht das zu benutzen, was bei Wikidata drin steht.
Das heißt, Wikidata erfüllt, es ist auch quasi so ein Werkzeug eigentlich für Autoren, um so den Wahrheiten besser auf die Spur zu kommen?
Ja, hoffen wir, dass das mal so wird, genau. Aber es wird auch schon, wie gesagt, es gibt ja diese Trennung zwischen Repository und Client. Es wird als Client auf Wikipedien auch schon unterschiedlich eingesetzt. Also meine Lieblingskleine Sprache, Occidental. Da gab es, vor einiger Zeit bin ich da drauf gestoßen, weil ich einen Blogbeitrag gelesen habe, wie ich die Occidental Wikipedia bearbeitet habe, ohne die Sprache zu kennen. Occidental benutzt Infoboxen, die aus Wikidata gefüllt werden. Dieser Mensch aus der niederländischen Wikipedia guckte sich da halt durch. Das ist halt so eine romanische Sprache, wo man so ein bisschen raten kann, worum es geht. Aber nur dadurch, dass man es irgendwie rät, hat man nicht unbedingt die Qualifikation, da wirklich als Autor mitzuarbeiten. Und er sah dann halt in der Infobox, naja, das kann nicht so ganz stimmen. Und da das halt in Wikidata eingetragen war, ist er dann zu dem entsprechenden Wikidata-Item gegangen, hat den Wert geändert, ist wieder auf diese Occidental-Wikipedia gegangen, wo man halt so die Sprache erraten kann, aber nicht wirklich spricht. Und sah dann halt, ja, jetzt steht da der korrekte Wert drin. Und ich hab als Autor quasi mitgeholfen, obwohl ich die Sprache an sich gar nicht kenne.
Jetzt guck ich grad mal, Deutschland, Alemanha, gut gefüllt eigentlich.
Genau.
Ah, und hier steht dann auch schon... Da merkt man schon, dass das auch noch alles ein bisschen im Entstehen ist.
Aber... Was man auch irgendwie, wenn du mal anfangst, dieser Infobox, da haben wir, na warte, General, irgendwas. Und dann siehst du da, plötzlich steht da unvermittelt Q133018. Also dieses Wikidata-Item hat noch kein Label, noch kein Titel in Occitan eingetragen.
Lustig. Mal gucken, was das für ein Label ist, was hier in der Sprache noch nicht benannt ist. Ah, Bundeswappen Deutschlands.
Ja, für die Occitansprachigen Zuhörer dieses Podcasts, da ist noch Mitarbeit gefragt.
Ja, aber es ist super, weil die Information ist abgebildet, ohne dass die Sprache selbst zum Einsatz kommen muss. Es liefert einfach auch interessante neue Vorlagen für eine Mitarbeit, die so vorher nicht da gewesen ist. Normalerweise wäre diese Information gar nicht da gewesen. Aber jetzt weiß man zumindest schon mal, wo man hingehen muss, wo man es eintragen kann. Und dann ist das Album auch gleich universell gültig. Interessant. Jetzt haben wir so die Items und die Properties plus diese Wikipedia, Wikimedia Service der Verlinkung gehabt. Da gab es noch irgendwas mit Abfragen in irgendeiner Form. Also wie kriegt man denn jetzt diese Daten da so hin, in so eine Infobox? Wenn da Skripte laufen, d.h. da muss dann programmiert werden. Schön, dass das jetzt alles so strukturiert vorliegt. Aber wie kommt man denn da jetzt eigentlich so ran? Wie blenden sich diese Informationen so magisch ein?
Ja, da gibt es mehrere Möglichkeiten. Also erstmal hat Wikidata, wie alle Media Wikis, eine API, also ein Programmier-Interface. Und das ist für mich auch eins der seltsamerweise am besten gehüteten Geheimnisse von Media Wiki. Das ist halt irgendwie ein richtig schicke, gut dokumentierter API hat, die außer ein paar Frohlenuts irgendwie niemand benutzt.
Wahrscheinlich war man davon ausgegangen, dass man dann immer so Wikitext vor die Nase geballert bekommt, den man dann erstmal selber parsen darf.
Richtig. Also wenn ich jetzt hier unter www.wikidata.org/wanstattwiki und dann api.php eingebe, das tue ich jetzt hier mal live, dann sehe ich halt irgendwie, das ist der api Endpunkt und da ist dann halt auch alles dokumentiert.
Das ist autogenerierte Wikimedia-Hanschlauch. Media-Wiki-api.
Das ist ein Grundsätzlichproblem, das haben wir auch auf der Arbeit, irgendwie dreimal am Tag. Also mit Wikipedia, Wikimedia, Media-Wiki.
Also wirklich ein lustiger Namespace-Haufen, aber es macht einen irgendwann echt ein bisschen kaputt.
Okay, und da haben wir verschiedene Funktionen und die werden auch dann entsprechend angereichert und die Dokumentation sieht dann auch bei jedem anders aus, je nachdem welche Extensions gesagt werden. Wir müssen das auch hier nicht alles durchgehen.
Nee, lass dich, aber es gibt eine.
Es gibt, wenn du mal nach WB Get Entities, also für Wikibase Get Entities, suchst du bitte.
AP Module to get the data for multiple Wikibase Entities.
Und ich glaube, wenn du da runter scrollst, gibt es sogar ein Beispiel. API Action WB Get Entities IDs Q42.
Ja, hole alle Entities mit der ID Q42 mit allen Attributen in allen Sprachen.
Klick da doch mal drauf.
Q42.
Und wir bekommen XML zurück. Und wenn wir da jetzt mit Ampersand, also auf jeden Fall kann ich das auch noch in verschiedenen anderen Formaten. Ich kann das in JSON mir ausgeben lassen. Es gibt verschiedene Varianten von XML, die ich ausgeben kann und ich hab's dann halt in Maschinenlesbar. Und da bekomme ich auch erst mal einen ganz schönen Klumpen zurück, nämlich alle Sprachen. Ich kann das aber auch eingrenzen, dass ich das nur mit den deutschen Labels haben will oder nur Deutsch und Englisch oder nur Englisch. Und wenn es Englisch nicht gibt, dann fall back auf Deutsch. Solche Sachen.
Und dann sehen wir auch gleich hier schön in XML, dass natürlich Q42 niemand anderes ist als Douglas Noelle Adams. Sehr schön.
Ja, also wir haben diese Software entwickelt und eine Motivation, diese Software zu entwickeln war, dass wir... Es könnte noch mehr sein, es könnte auch noch viel weniger sein. Wer zum Beispiel Chinesisch kann, wird sich vielleicht fragen.
Q666.
Ja, das ist nichts, das wäre zu offensichtlich gewesen. Aber Q13.
Die Number of the Beasts ist das hier.
Stimmt, stimmt, stimmt. Was ist damit Q13 zum.
Ja, bitte vorlesen, in welcher Sprache hättest du es denn gerne? Also in Italienisch ist es die Triscaidecafobia.
Was ist denn hier DE? Da und da, ziemlich weit oben.
Die Triscaidecaphobie, also die Angst vor der 13.
Guck an, was es alles gibt. Wenn man Chinesisch kann, dann kann man sich wahrscheinlich schon denken, was das Item Nummer 4 ist.
Ah, die haben es nicht so mit der 4, ne? Ah, 4 ist der Tod.
Genau. Warum es dann häufig in chinesischen Gebäuden keinen vierten Stock gibt, weil Tod und 4 gleich ausgesprochen werden und das bringt Unglück. Andererseits gibt es auch Glückszahlen wie die 8.
Tod und 4. Wie weißt du, wie man das ausspricht?
Also, wenn jetzt jemand Chinesisch kann, soll er mich kontrollieren. Ich glaube, ich schieh irgendwas. Ich weiß, dass das auf Japanisch und Koreanisch das gleiche ist und auf Koreanisch wird beides Sa ausgesprochen.
Gut. Wo waren wir denn jetzt eigentlich stehen geblieben?
Wir waren bei der API.
Wir waren bei der API. Die eigentliche Frage war, wie kommt man da ran? API, okay, das heißt, jetzt kann ich mir ein Programm schreiben und direkt auf wikidata.org draufgehen und kriege halt all diese ganzen Aussagen, die dort sind, so weit runtergefiltert, wie ich das gerne haben möchte.
Ich kann nicht nur die Aussagen bekommen, sondern ich kann sie auch editieren und raufschreiben. Es gibt ein super tolles Framework, das zuerst für Wikipedia eingesetzt worden ist. API, Wikipedia, das ist für Bot-Autoren unersetzlich. Also es ist ein Python-Framework, wo du halt dann wirklich sagen kannst, hier das und das editieren, den Wert rauslutschen und so. Und das ist für API, Wikidata dann auch umgesetzt. Also ganz, ganz viele Leute arbeiten einfach so, dass sie sagen, hier, ich hab einen Datensatz bekommen von der chinesischen Behörde und ich trag jetzt mal einfach dieses Wochenende alle Namen von chinesischen Provinzen ein und lass dann Python-Script schreiben. Also das ist halt wirklich diese Bot-Freundlichkeit, die wir da bei Wikidata haben. Ja, das läuft dann halt über die API und du schreibst dann deine Python-Scripts mit PyWikiData, die dann auf die API zugreifen. Das ist der eine Weg. Der andere Weg, wenn du nicht über die API gehst, und das bietet sich eigentlich nicht an, auch wenn das alles dokumentiert ist, machst du das normalerweise nicht bei Hand, diese Abfragen, sondern schreibst irgendwie einen Skript und so. Der andere Weg ist, dass du natürlich auch, alle Wikipedien sind halt Wikidata-Clients und können in einer gewissen Art und Weise auf Wikidata auch zugreifen. Da hat sich ganz gut getroffen, dass im Moment bei Wikipedia sich Gedanken gemacht wird über programmierbare Templates, programmierbare Vorlagen, zum Beispiel Vorlagen für Infoboxen und sowas. Da passiert gerade eine Menge. Es gibt eine eigene Template-Programmiersprache, die in MediaWiki drin ist. Damit komplexe Probleme zu lösen, ist echt schwer, weil das irgendwann sehr, sehr unübersichtlich wird. Und nach einigen im Hin und Her haben sich die Entwickler von MediaWiki dazu durchgerungen, zu sagen, hier wir brauchen eine Skriptsprache, die in MediaWiki selber läuft. Und mit der ich dann sowas wie If-Abfragen und Schleifen und sowas machen kann, damit ich dann programmatisch Wiki-Text erzeugen kann, zum Beispiel für Infoboxen. Diese Skriptsprache, die da eingebaut wird, nennt sich Lua. Lua kennen die einen. Der eine oder andere vielleicht als Skriptsprache, die im Bereich der Computerspiele viel benutzt wird. Alles, was über Config-Files hinausgeht, wo man ein bisschen Logik braucht. Hier eine Schleife, da eine If-Abfrage. Da linkt man gerne mal den Lua-Interpreter dagegen, weil der einfach so super leichtgewichtig ist und nur ein paar Kilobyte mitbringt. Und einfach sehr gut als Embedded-Skriptsprache läuft. Das gibt es jetzt auch bei MediaWiki.
Das ist jetzt schon Teil des normalen MediaWiki-Releases?
Nein, das ist eine Extension, die du noch dazu installieren musst. Aber diese Extension ist auf allen Wikipedien deployed. Sie nennt sich Scribuntu. Das ist lateinisch für sie sollen schreiben. Scribuntu ist auch ein bisschen grundsätzlicher aufgebaut. Jetzt gibt es das halt in der Form, dass da Lua drin läuft. Aber die ursprüngliche Überlegung war halt, einfach eine Sandbox zu bauen für grundsätzliche Skriptsprachen. Also sehr, sehr gewünscht wäre Javascript, das ist halt nicht machbar. Aber mal gucken, was in der Zukunft dann noch passiert.
Das heißt, man würde mit Scribuntu aus einem anderen Wikidata heraus auf Wikidata zugreifen?
In Scribuntu kann ich erstmal Lua-Skripte schreiben, die programmatisch Wikitext erzeugen. Zum Beispiel für Vorlagen, zum Beispiel für befüllte Infoboxen und so. Und was wir dann bei Wikidata gemacht haben, bei der Wikibase-Software gemacht haben, ist, dass wir in diesen Lua-Namespace dann noch Funktionen rein exportieren, sodass ich dann auf das Item, was auf dieser Seite besprochen wird, zugreifen kann, da den ganzen Properties rausnehmen kann und das dann halt entsprechend mit Lua schleifen, durchlaufen kann, filtern kann, map, was weiß ich, was ich damit machen möchte.
Was wäre zum Beispiel jetzt so eine Anwendung dafür?
Na, eine Infobox wäre eine super Anwendung. Dann habe ich halt irgendwie von Anfang an alles, was Wikidata über den Seitengegenstand weiß, als Lua-Datenstruktur, als Table, also als assoziatives Array vorliegen, kann dadurch hopsen und kann mir das filtern, so wie ich es gerne hätte.
Das heißt, damit könnte ich dann auch problemlos, oder zumindest wäre es machbar, die Liste der weiblichen Bürgermeister aus den größten Städten zu bauen?
Nicht ganz, denn dazu müsste Wikidata erst etwas haben, wo jetzt gerade mit Hochdruck dann gearbeitet wird. Wikidata müsste neben Items und Properties noch eine dritte Sache haben, nämlich sogenannte Queries.
Warum müsste es das haben?
Weil ich damit halt Abfragen stellen kann, die über mehrere Items gehen. Genau, und Items miteinander verknüpfen und so weiter.
Das heißt, mit dieser bisherigen Scripting-Lösung kann ich quasi nur auf ein Item zugreifen?
Ich kann mir halt ein Item holen und da dann die Properties durch… wenn ich halt weiß, welches Item das ist und so, dann kann ich damit irgendwie Zeug machen. Aber was ich ja wirklich haben will ist…
Gib mir alle Objekte, die folgenden Entsprechungen genügen. Und dazu muss dann quasi Wikidata selber eine Query-Language bereithalten. Und das ist das, was gerade gebaut wird.
Das ist das, was gerade gebaut wird. Und das ist auch noch eine sehr komplexe Aufgabe. Also da wird auch noch so einiges Wasser, die Spree runterlaufen, bis das irgendwie dann auch anwendbar ist. Leider. Also der ursprüngliche Zeitpan war, dass das alles zum jetzigen Zeitpunkt schon fertig ist und dass zumindest einfache Anfragen jetzt schon funktionieren sollen. Aber ja, da hat sich einfach die Komplexität des Problems dann in der Praxis gezeigt.
Ja, aber du bist dann zuversichtlich, dass das kommt?
Na klar, ich hab's schon gesehen. Also man kann schon die ersten Anfänge davon irgendwie im Git-Repo und so weiter sehen. Aber bis es dann halt wirklich lauffähig auf Wikidata im Internet ist, das dauert noch ein bisschen.
An der Stelle wäre wahrscheinlich nochmal ganz interessant, nochmal auf diesen Unterschied hinzuweisen. Also es gibt Wikipedia und es gibt MediaWiki. Und MediaWiki ist die Software, die eine Wikipedia realisiert. Es gibt Wikidata...
Und die auch nicht nur für Wikipedia eingesetzt wird.
Genau, darauf wollte ich jetzt eigentlich hinaus. Aber nur, um mal so die Begriffswelten da klarzumachen. Dann gibt es Wikidata, das Projekt mit ihrer konkreten Ausprägung, wikidata.org. Und da kommt auch MediaWiki zum Einsatz, aber eben bereichert um die Extensions. Die heißen Wikibase.
Die Software, die wir da gemacht haben, heißt Wikibase. Da gibt es noch viele kleine andere Extensions, die noch dazugehören, DataValues, DIV und so weiter.
Aber die hat quasi so eine Server und so eine Kleinkomponente. Und in Wikipedia ist diese Kleinkomponente deployed und nur in Wikidata ist dann quasi auch der Server, also das Repo, genau wie das so schön heißt. Das heißt, das ist alles offene Software. Und wenn ich jetzt der Meinung bin, ich will jetzt aber meine eigene Datensammlung haben und ich hätte das aber auch gerne so hübsch mit Aussagenlogik und Mehrsprachigkeit und Property-Welten. Und ich kann hier mehrere Behauptungen nebeneinander stellen und sie widersprechen sich vielleicht inhaltlich, aber zumindest nicht in der Software. Dann kann ich mir im Prinzip so ein Media-Wiki ziehen mit diesen ganzen Wikibase-Kram, einschließlich eben dieses Repos. Und dann kann ich in so einer Wiki-Instanz mir quasi so meine eigene Datenwelt zusammenbauen.
Richtig.
Und wenn ich jetzt der Meinung bin, es wird mal Zeit für ein EAN Produktverzeichnis Deutschlands, dann wäre das zum Beispiel schon mal der richtige Ort, weil ich könnte ja morgen anfangen zu sagen, hier, wir tragen jetzt mal Informationen über alle Produkte, die so im Verkauf sind, zusammen. Da kann jeder drin herumeditieren und wir kategorisieren das. Aber wenn ich jetzt damit anfangen würde, das in Wikidata und damit ja quasi für die Wikipedia einzutragen, dann würde ich wahrscheinlich sofort erschlagen werden.
Ja klar, also es wäre auch komplett irrelevant für den Scope des Projektes.
Genau, wenn ich mal so ein totaler Barcode-Nerd ist oder wenn ich jetzt vielleicht auch mal so die Basis schaffen möchte, wovon ich immer so ein bisschen träume, ja so die App auf meinem Smartphone, die mal eben so ein EAN passt und dann ein Lookup macht auf einer Datenbank, da finden wir dann immer so die Datenbank dafür. Da gibt es ja irgendwie nichts offener. Vielleicht gibt es irgendwas, kenne ich nicht, keine Ahnung.
Da würde sich Wikibase tatsächlich echt gut vereignen.
Ja, weil da kann dann jeder sein Kram zu eintragen und vor allem kann man auch so verschiedene Aussagen dazu zusammenfassen.
Und da hättest du wahrscheinlich wieder genau das, was auch bei Wikidata ist, dass du mal irgendwie einen Klumpen Dumps irgendwie kriegst, wo du dann halt einen Pilsen-Skript schreibst und das einfach mal in ein paar Sekunden importierst.
War mal einfach mal hier so eine Produktdatenbank irgendwo abgeschmolzen.
Aber auch wieder den Fall, dass du irgendwie im Supermarkt stehst, oh, das gibt es noch nicht, dann trage ich das schnell per Hand ein.
Genau, so, neues Produkt, pipa po, und dann hat man Spaß dran und sagt, ja, ist irgendwie, ist eine Instanz von Margarine und der Hersteller ist, und hier ist der Eintrag bei Stiftung Warentest und da, ja, ich denke da in die richtige Richtung, ja?
Absolut, also würden wir uns auch sehr freuen, wenn es wirklich schöne Installationen von Wikibase gibt, die über Wikidata hinausgehen.
Aber so eine Abfrage, so wie sie jetzt gerade gesagt haben, mit gib mir mal alle Artikel, also alle EAN-Nummern, die sozusagen Margarine sind, das lässt sich technisch gerade noch gar nicht realisieren.
Ein bisschen über Umwege, aber richtig schön wird es, wenn halt diese Query-Language dann auch am Laufen ist und wir dann, ja, wenn das dann alles irgendwie fluffig ist.
Okay, das wäre dann quasi die Voraussetzung.
Aber was du natürlich immer jetzt machen kannst, ist, dass du so Sachen machen kannst, wie dieses Property, auf welche Seiten zeigt das und so weiter, wo wird das verwendet. Also das kannst du ja jetzt schon abschneiden. Aber komplexe Queries gehen so weiter nicht. Obwohl es da schon eine sehr hübsche Demo gibt für Wikidata-Query. Da gibt es auch wieder von Magnus Manske, der Mensch ohne Freizeit, der die Freizeit benutzt, um komplett nur Tools für Wikidata zu schreiben, die schon mal ein bisschen in die Zukunft von Wikidata gehen. Und der hat natürlich auch schon eine Queriesprache entwickelt. Und das funktioniert auch schon erstaunlich gut. Und das, obwohl er nicht auf Wikidata selber zugreift, sondern auf einen Datenbank-Dump von Wikidata, der halt im schlimmsten Fall so ein paar Stunden alt sein kann. Und da kann man jetzt schon...
Hier kann ich es suchen nach Podcastern. Passend-Go-Create-Podcasts findet aber keiner.
Machen wir mal dieses männliche da weg. Da haben wir jetzt irgendwie zwei Results. Tim Pritlove und Holger Klein, das sind die beiden Podcaster, die es in der Welt gibt.
Noch nicht ganz so weit durchgesetzt. Na gut, aber es ist ja da.
Da kann man auch ein bisschen was verknüpfen. Ich glaube, da ist gerade die Verknüpfung nicht ganz richtig gemacht, aber es gibt auch die Möglichkeit sowohl das als auch das. Dann kann man genau das machen, was wir am Anfang besprochen haben.
Aber es ist auf jeden Fall noch eine Entwicklung, aber es kommt.
Ja, es gibt auf jeden Fall schon schöne Sachen, die man machen kann.
Ja, Mensch, Jens, das ist ja eigentlich ein tolles Ding. Wirft denn das nicht dann auch nochmal so eine Myriade an rechtlichen Fragen auf sich? Gab es da auch irgendwelche juristischen?
Ja, das Ganze ist halt eingebettet in dieses Wikimedia-Movement, die sich ja sehr festlegen auf freies Wissen und freie Lizenzen. Also bis hin, dass für Wikipedia mal eine freie Lizenz durch, ja, umgeschrieben wurde von Richard Stormann persönlich. Es gibt diese GNU-Free Documentation License, die vom GNU-Projekt eingesetzt wird. Und früher war alles, was unter Wikipedia veröffentlicht war, unter dieser GNU-Free Documentation License. Das passt auch so ein bisschen irgendwie, also nicht wirklich, also die Artikel in Wikipedia sind nicht wirklich Software-Dokumentation, aber das war irgendwie so damals das, was am ersten da so in die Richtung ging. Und dann kam eine Bewegung durch Lawrence Lessig ins Leben gerufen, freie Inhalte für beliebige Kulturgüter, Creative Commons, und bei Wikipedia wollte man dann gerne auf diese Creative Commons License wechseln, was so in dieser GNU-Free Documentation License nicht vorgesehen ist. Also bei ganz vielen freien Lizenzen, wenn du dich einmal festgelegt hast, dann kannst du nicht morgen sagen, dass die Batch doch proprietär ist, sondern einmal unter einer Lizenz rausgegeben, kann die halt nicht mehr verändert werden.
Ja, und gerade so in der GPL-Landschaft ist ja dieses virale Selbsterhaltungselement schon immer auch ein Prinzip gewesen.
Ja, und da wurde halt viel diskutiert und rumverhandelt und so, und da halt irgendwie da drin stand GNU-Free Documentation License in der Version so und so, oder eine spätere Version. Wurde dann in einer späteren Version sozusagen das Lex Wikipedia eingefügt, das dann gesagt wird, ja, kannst du halt nicht wechseln, außer du betreibst zufällig ein Online-Lexikon-Projekt mit so und so viel Einträgen und so und so viel Mitarbeitern, dann kannst du in einem Zeitraum von Monat X bis Monat Y in dem und dem Jahr die Lizenz auch wechseln. Ja, und da wurde dann umgeschaltet auf Creative Commons.
Ja, aber steht denn jetzt die Wikidata-Inhalte auch unter derselben?
Nein, die stehen nicht unter Creative Commons bei Share Alike, wie die Artikel, also Namensnennung plus Weitergabe unter gleichen Bedingungen, sondern das steht unter CC0. Und das ist das, was die meisten Menschen unter Public Domain kennen. Public Domain ist ein Begriff aus dem amerikanischen Recht und ist in Deutschland nicht wirklich verankert. Also es gibt den Begriff gemeinfrei, aber es gibt nicht in allen Ausprägungen dieses Ding Public Domain. Und CC0 sagt einfach, mach damit, was du willst. Du musst keine Namensnennung betreiben. Du musst es nicht unter speziellen Bedingungen dann wieder weitergeben. Und ob du es kommerziell nutzt oder nicht, das ist auch völlig egal. Und das ist eigentlich das einzige, was sich dann rausgestellt hat, was bei Datenbanken und Datenbank-Sammlungen sinnvoll ist. Es gibt leider in vielen Jurisdiktionen, auch glaube ich in der EU, so eine Tendenz, sowas wie ein Datenbankrecht für Datenbank, Sammlungs, Urheberrechts, sonst was Ansprüche zu stellen. Ich habe die Angst, dass wenn sich das wirklich durchsetzt und wenn da bestimmte schlimme Dinge zusammenkommen, dass uns das ganz schön viel an freien Wissen und offenen Daten abkappen kann für immer. Denn das Einzige, was für solche Informationen wie diese Person hat das und das Geschlecht, diese Stadt hat so viel Einwohner, für solche Mini-Informationen wirklich machbar ist, ist wirklich CC0 und da jetzt bei jeder Abfrage, bei jedem View auf diese Daten auch noch sowas zu machen wie eine Urheberrechtsangabe, selbst wenn ich es frei verwenden kann, dann eine Urheberrechtsangabe, das ist einfach nicht machbar. Und da ist dann bei Wikidata im Gegensatz zu allen anderen Wikimedia-Projekten beschlossen worden, alles was in Wikidata reinkommt, ist CC0. Du musst auch, wenn du ein Wert einfügst, kommt ein kleines Pop-Up. Da hat uns das Justizierat von der Foundation zu geraten. So seien sie sich bewusst, wenn sie hier was eintragen, verlieren sie alle Urheberrechte daran. Oder niemand darf auch da Urheberrechte haben.
Das wäre auch, glaube ich, ein bisschen der Wahnsinn.
Das wäre wirklich der Wahnsinn.
Wirklich jetzt auch noch ein Urheberrecht an dem Festhalten einer Behauptung.
Und doch ist es so, dass heutzutage da irgendwie viel dran geschraubt wird. Und es irgendwie mächtige Player gibt, die sowas wie ein Datenbank-Urheberrecht, für das Kurieren, für die kuratorische Leistung der Zusammenstellung einer Datenbank, möchte ich dann auch entlohnt werden und so weiter. Im Moment gibt es halt in der EU große Debatten über Reform des Urheberrechts. Das wird uns in den nächsten ein, zwei Jahren richtig beschäftigen. Und da werden gerade Schlachten geschlagen. Vielleicht auch ein bisschen fernab von dem, was die meisten mitkriegen. Aber das wird nochmal neu aufgerollt. Und ich freue mich sehr, dass Wikidata so einen klaren Standpunkt einnimmt und sagt, CC0 ist für Datenbanken das einzige, was zählt.
Wie siehst du denn jetzt so die Entwicklung? Also was erhoffst du dir auf der einen Seite? Was denkst du ist unabwendbare Entwicklung? Was könnte sich vielleicht einstellen, wenn es gut läuft? Was ist so ein bisschen so diese Vision über wir haben hier eine Liste aller Wikipedia-Artikel, die auf den gleichen Begriff zusammenkommen?
Erstmal denke ich, dass das Projekt wirklich ganz am Anfang steht. Also es ist jetzt knapp über ein Jahr alt. Erster Geburtstag vor kurzem gefeiert, also im Oktober glaube ich. Und was in der Zeit erreicht wird, ist schon unglaublich, aber wenn man ganz groß träumt, dann doch im begrenzten Rahmen. Andererseits, wenn ich mir die Wikipedia heute angucke und die Wikipedia von 2002, dann sehe ich schon, was so über zehn Jahre für einen Unterschied machen. Und ja, bei Wikidata, das ist halt auch wirklich ein langfristiges Ding. Und das volle Potenzial wird wirklich dann in ein paar Jahren wahrscheinlich erst entfesselt werden. Wahrscheinlich auch in der Form, dass wir gar nicht mehr merken, dass wir Wikidata benutzen. Kann ich mir sehr gut vorstellen. Bei der Wikipedia ist es den meisten Leuten noch bewusst, dass sie Sachen in der Wikipedia lesen. Aber ich kann mir gut vorstellen, dass bei Wikidata das einfach Teil dieser Wissensfolge wird, die um uns herumschwirrt, die unsere Welt in irgendeiner Art und Weise strukturiert oder strukturierbar macht. Und wir in den meisten Fällen gar nicht bewusst wahrnehmen, dass wir gerade ein View auf Wikidata sehen oder eine Query an Wikidata stellen. Sondern das ist einfach die Benutzung des Internets.
Weil man muss ja, wenn man es jetzt mal eigentlich vielleicht nochmal aus diesem Blickwinkel auch gerade rückt, das ist zwar jetzt Teil von Wikimedia, der Wikimedia-Community, Teil der Wikipedia-Community. Es leistet eine große Dienstleistung jetzt schon für Wikipedia und wird noch sehr viel mehr das tun. Aber die dort gesammelten Daten, die ja auch lizenzrechtlich, wie wir jetzt wissen, sehr frei sind, können direkt in alles Mögliche eingeblendet und transferiert werden. Auch, was mit Wikipedia-Inhalten so erstmal per se gar nichts zu tun hat. Also egal, was für Artikel da existieren, wie umfangreich oder exzellent oder umstritten die sind. Es ist einfach ein Ort, in dem Aussagen über die Welt gesammelt werden.
Richtig. Und ein Behauptungskatalog. Ist auch nicht der einzige dieser Form. Da gibt es natürlich neben der freien Bewegung für freies Wissen und immer mit netten Lizenzen und so, gibt es natürlich auch im kommerziellen Bereich Player, die sich da sehr interessieren. Ich kann mir gut vorstellen, dass das, was wir bei Wolfram Alpha sehen, irgendwann zusammenfallen wird mit Wikidata. Oder dass die beiden Projekte entweder direkt gegeneinander, oder was heißt gegeneinander, das ist sehr schwer.
Ich meine, Wolfram Alpha wäre ja schön blöd, wenn sie sich nicht letztlich auch der Wikidata-Quellen benutzen würden.
Ja, machen sie auch. Jetzt schon. Ne, also gegeneinander ist natürlich nicht der richtige Ansatz. Weil etwas, was für alle frei ist, dann, ich meine natürlich keinen Wolfram Alpha, aber dass das Wikidata vielleicht irgendwie in eine ähnliche Richtung gehen wird. Oder dass das, was dann für uns irgendwie in ein paar Jahren das Internet sein wird, auch solche Wissens-Daten-Fundos-Apparate wie Wolfram Alpha oder das, was dann Wikidata sein wird, einschließt. Ich muss jetzt irgendwie total esoterisch dahin quatschen, aber es ist einfach schwierig, technologische Aussagen über so einen langen Zeitraum zu machen. Ich habe so ein bisschen Träume, in welche Richtung das gehen kann, aber es wäre einfach unverantwortlich zu sagen, in fünf Jahren sieht das Internet dann so und so aus. Aber ich glaube, in fünf Jahren wird der Begriff strukturierte Daten auf jeden Fall nichts mehr exotisches sein, was man erklären muss, sondern das wird ähnlich wie irgendwann sowas wie eine grafische Benutzeroberfläche einfach Teil des Allgemeinwissens geworden ist und nichts mehr ist, was man erklären musste, werden strukturierte Daten einfach Teil davon sein, wie wir mit dem Internet umgehen.
Ich glaube, 2013 ist eh das Jahr, was so als das Jahr der Metadaten in die Geschichte eingehen wird, mit dem ganzen NSA-Skandal, dem neuen Verständnis von Überwachungstechnologie und ihrem Wert, also allein das Betrachten der Metadaten, was es einfach für Aufschlüsse generieren kann. Und genauso, ich meine, Geheimdienste sind die eine Sache, aber wenn wir jetzt mal eben sagen, zum Nutzen der Gesellschaft, wir sammeln einfach mal die Metadaten der Welt, und schauen mal, was wir daraus Sinnvolles schaffen können, um eben mal schöne Graphen zu plotten, die einfach dieses Wissen interpretieren und die uns einfach Wahrheiten und mögliche Wahrheiten liefern darüber, was eben Sache ist. Ich finde das eigentlich ganz spannend. Ich meine, Voraussagen mit der Zukunft usw. ist alles eine schwierige Sache, aber was ja vielleicht etwas überschaubarer ist, sind so die unmittelbaren Auswirkungen auf die Wikipedia. Das hat man teilweise schon angesprochen, so diese Infobox und etc. Projekte wie Wikispecies und Wiktionary werden dann wahrscheinlich aufgehen in Wikidata, oder?
Das ist so eine Aussage, die würde ich gegenüber den sehr engagierten Mitarbeitern von diesen Projekten echt nicht so...
Ja gut, ich meine, das Endergebnis wird noch dasselbe sein. Nur ihre Realisierung wird anders sein, oder?
Also ich weiß, dass es halt irgendwie so was Ähnliches wie einen Zeitplan gibt. Und wir werden letztendlich alle Wikimedia-Projekte in irgendeiner Form mit Wikidata unterstützen. Oder die werden alle Wikidata in irgendeiner Form integrieren. Den Plan bei Wikispecies weiß ich nicht. Ich weiß, dass Wiktionary am Ende stehen wird von diesem Fahrplan. Weil dieses Wörterbuch, das mehrsprachig ist und dann mehrsprachig verschiedene grammatische Kategorien und was was ich dann irgendwie aufschlüsselt, das ist wahrscheinlich das Komplexeste, um das abzubilden in Wikidata. Und das wird auf jeden Fall noch etliche Monate dauern, vielleicht sogar Jahre.
Aber das ist schon mal ein sehr schöner Schleifstein, an dem so ein Projekt dann auch sich polieren kann.
Genau, wenn Wiktionary komplett integriert ist in Wikidata, dann ist erstmal so der konkrete Plan fertig.
Dann ist schon mal so das Wichtigste geschafft.
Dann haben alle Projekte, die unter der Wikimedia Foundation betrieben werden, irgendeine Unterstützung von Wikidata erfahren. Und das ist so der konkrete Plan und weiter wird dann auch in die Zukunft nicht geplant. Und die Arbeit an diesem Open-Source-Projekt wird auf jeden Fall weitergehen. Und da werden immer noch spannende Sachen. Und ich bin jetzt schon überrascht. Also ich bin überrascht über diese Community, die irgendwie lustige Dinge macht, dass man dann einfach so eine Webseite wie gdata.org aufmacht. Und es bilden sich Strukturen so hier, wir brauchen unbedingt eine Taskforce, Pokémon. Wir müssen alle Pokémon-Arten in der Welt halt katalogisieren nach strukturierten Daten und so. Niemand hat sich drum gebeten. Die waren einfach da und haben sich selbst organisiert. Genauso die Tools, die halt Magnus Manske irgendwie fast im Wochenrhythmus raushaut und irgendwie Sachen macht wie eine Zeit- und geografische Zeitstrahldarstellung von Kriegen oder sowas, wo man dann sehen kann, da auf der Karte ist das. Da im Zeitstrahl des Krieges ist das dann passiert. Das ist ein Bild, ein Gemälde dazu von Wikimedia Commons und so weiter. Das ist einfach fantastisch, was man da jetzt schon macht, ohne dass wir als Entwickler von dieser Wikibase-Software da irgendwie einen Finger krümmen müssen. Genau, weil du da auch gerade Wikidata-Query aufhast. Eine sehr komplexe Query ist zum Beispiel alle Brücken in Deutschland. Das ist da als letztes, als Example irgendwie.
Ah, kann man einklicken.
Und dann macht er dir einen Überblick über alles, was in Deutschland ist oder in einer administrativen Unterheimheit von Deutschland ist und eine Instanz von Brücke ist und so weiter und so weiter. Also ja, gerade diese Query-Geschichte, das wird nochmal ein ganz großer Schub für das Projekt sein.
Worauf sollte man sich jetzt so stürzen, wenn man da irgendwie Spaß hat mit Daten, Datenspaß?
Also gibt es immer was zu tun? Es gibt auch so eine Liste.
Wer sollte sich sozusagen drauf stürzen? Also für welche Gruppen ist es denn vielleicht noch interessant, abgesehen jetzt von den offensichtlichen Programmierern?
Ja, die offensichtlichen Programmierer bekommen auf jeden Fall gut zu tun. Es gibt eine eigene Seite für Bot-Requests, wo Leute Sachen reinschreiben wie es gibt doch die und die Sammlung von offenen Daten, irgendwie Personenverzeichnis von irgendeiner chinesischen Behörde und so weiter. Ich hätte die Daten da, mag jemand mal einen Bot schreiben, der das mal alles rein importiert?
Also um es überhaupt erstmal zu befüllen.
Genau, und da gibt es so einiges. Es gibt eine To-Do-Seite, wo dann drin steht hier, diese Items sind zum Beispiel Werke oder Bücher, aber die haben noch keinen Autor verzeichnet, also da könnte man sich dann austoben. Es gibt so kleine Gadgets, die man sich auf dieser Tool-Seite dann auch installieren kann. Javascript-Code, der noch nachgeladen werden kann, und da kann man dann sehen, okay, in den und den Sprachen, die ich spreche, hat dieses Item kein Label, also kein Titel und hat auch keine Beschreibung. Und da kann ich doch mal schnell was nachtragen. Also ich könnte da jetzt schnell sagen, wie dieses Item auf Deutsch heißt oder sowas. Es gibt ein ganz fetziges Teil, das ist irgendwie die Concept Cloud. Da suchst du dir zum Beispiel ein Item wie Q42, also Douglas Adams, raus. Und gibst das dann ihr Concept Cloud an. Und der durchsucht dann sowohl Wikidata als auch die Wikipedien, die darauf... Da ist glaube ich der Link, der da irgendwie mit Concept Cloud... Er sucht dann halt die ganzen Wikipedien, alle Dinge, die irgendwie noch mit damit zu tun haben. Und kommt dann erstmal auf sehr, sehr interessante Ergebnisse. Also ja, klar hat das irgendwie auch was damit zu tun. Und da zeigt er dann auch an, hier guck mal in der Sprache, gibt es dafür noch kein Label und solche Sachen.
Ja, also ich sehe da auch eine Menge Möglichkeiten, auch gerade so in diesen populären neuen Daten-Journalismus-Welten, hier neue Quellen zu finden, um einfach Zusammenhänge klarer zu machen. Genealogien ist natürlich hier auch ein heißes Thema. Ich frage mich natürlich jetzt noch so ein bisschen, muss auch langsam mal zum Schluss kommen, aber wenn du sagst, ja, da schreib ich mal einen Bot und ich kippe dir jetzt mal irgendeine Datenbank rein. Ich meine, bei der Wikipedia waren das ja noch alles sehr manuelle Vorgänge. Es gibt zwar auch so Bots, aber die Bots, die legen ja nicht massiv neu an, sondern die, also mit den paar Ausnahmen, die wir schon besprochen haben, sondern die überarbeiten, finden Fehler etc. Solche Sachen geben Hinweise da drauf. Aber wenn jetzt so mehrere Bots daherkommen und dann so Billiarden an Kleinstmaterial da reingießen, da kommt auch kein Admin mehr hinterher.
Wird schwierig, ne? Aber einerseits kann man dann eine zweite Armada von Bots hinterher schicken, die dann aufräumt. Nein, also auch da ist, wenn du so massenhafte Bearbeitungen bei Media-Wiki vornemen willst, was du als Bot normalerweise machen möchtest, dann brauchst du ein gewisses Flag als User, ein Bot-Flag. Und auch da wird sich beworben. Und nützende Seite, da wird gesagt, hier, ich bin aber ein ganz guter Programmierer und habe schon ganz schön viel Erfahrung und gebe meinen Bot doch bitte das Bot-Flag. Und dann wird dann entschieden.
Sonst wird das halt gleich gesperrt, wenn da massiver Zugriff ist. Dann wird das sozusagen als Angriff gewehrt ist. Na, Jubet. Jens, müssen wir noch irgendwas nachtragen?
Die Zukunft wird auf jeden Fall spannend, strukturiert und bietet mehr Daten für alle.
Mehr Metadaten jetzt. Gut, dann bringen wir es mal zu Ende. Jens, vielen Dank. Das war Wikidata. Ich finde es ein spannendes Projekt. Ich hatte das erste Mal wieder dieses Gefühl, als ich mir das das erste Mal angeschaut habe, was ich hatte, auch als ich als erstes Mal auf Media-Wiki und die Wikipedia damit gestoßen bin. Das Gefühl, da hat mal jemand drüber nachgedacht. Das könnte vielleicht etwas werden.
Da haben tatsächlich Leute drüber nachgedacht. Und auch Leute, die zum Teil sehr viel klüger sind als ich.
So Ontologen halt. Gut, dann machen wir jetzt hier die Klappe zu. Ich sage danke an Jens und danke fürs Zuhören. Das war CRE205 und ich sage Tschüss und bis bald.